what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification Bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way in and
as you guys know if you have watched two
or more of my videos and you do not
subscribe we have beef okay beef people
a couple announcements before we start
the show the first is that we have two
clips channels just pearly clips and
pearl daily make sure you go subscribe
to both also guys we have four
membership tiers the first tier lets you
be a part of our live chat tonight if we
get a thousand likes we will open up the
stream to all members but we need to get
a thousand likes so till then sign up
for the first tier second tier you get
to see our Discord and our behind the
scenes Vlogs guys I can freestyle rap
you want to see it sign up for the
second Vlog sign up for the second tier
it's 10 bucks a month all right uh third
tier you get to connect with me on
social media and fourth tier you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month how
do you get a million subscribers in a
year I'll tell you sign up for the
fourth tier I can also give you a lot of
information if you want to put on a
podcast like this start your own live
show that sort of thing honestly guys
it's the best money you'll have ever
spent because I can I can save you so
much time and headache just with a
couple tips okay Instagram
um they took away my first Instagram so
go follow my second just pearly things
one
um we are also on wife School we're
trying to get 20 000 subscribers on wife
school and we have I think two or three
new episodes that are in the queue so
that they are going to be recorded you
know Melanie's helping me with my
fashion next week so um or follow wife
school also guys um we're doing a meet
up tomorrow 5 30 in central London I'm
at flat iron Square so if you guys want
to meet us you want to do a little get
together
um you don't need tickets you just show
up so um 5 30 Sunday also guys
um I
jpt
um is a network so just pearly things is
a network and we have two talents Auntie
Jenny um over there in the corner and um
King riches so make sure you go
subscribe to both we're trying to get
them to 100K in the next couple of
months so make sure you go subscribe to
both of their channels
um they do shows on the days I'm not
doing shows so there's always going to
be a show we are live six days a week
um also guys we have a new animation
Channel just pearly animations and we
have one official pregame account on
Instagram okay that's all my
announcements thank you
um okay today we have a lovely panel so
why don't we go around everyone say your
name your age your relationship status
and a fun fact about yourself
this can be anything from your job to a
hobby whatever
um so start here go around and then the
second row will go as well go ahead my
name is Michaela stack I'm 25 years old
I'm single
a fun fact is I flew from Ireland to be
here oh wow
I like your accent I like the Irish
accent it's very strong isn't it very
Dublin
hi everyone my name is Aisha AKA ish um
I am currently a uni student I also just
got off a five hour Coach just to be
here and um let's just say I'm a
struggling
um
just doing a lot of things but yeah
that's me
hi everyone my name is Lauren I am 33
years old I am dating and I am let's see
fun fact
I have been to 15 different countries
hi I'm Brittany I'm 23 currently single
um fun fact I love dogs I don't know
I want you Jenny
coming round but yeah I'm Auntie Jenny
I'm here all right
whatever everybody wait tell them about
your channel subscribe come on come on
subscribe to my channel
um yeah Auntie Jenny on YouTube thanks
bro
what up everybody MTR
video tutorials and reviews back again
all right Pearl's been working me over
here all right but we back in here
that's what we do
um I'm here on London on tour it's off
day so I came by with pearly
um yeah man follow me on Instagram to
try everything one sweet boy Twain yeah
hey guys I'm Melanie king
um I'm on YouTube
um also on social media just like a
Melanie king and a fun fact is that
um I don't even know a fun fact just
like look me up on YouTube you'll find a
lot of fun facts about me honestly
hi I'm Brooke I am a care worker
currently training to be a nurse the fun
fact about me is I'm on my mother for
free
hi I'm Robin
um I'm 26 and I'm a lingerie
photographer
oh what a lingerie photographer a
laundry yeah you take pictures of
laundry laundry
rooms
it's the angles it's all about the
angles so you do Boudoir yeah
okay okay
so today's topic
do modern women deserve respect now what
made me what made me think of this topic
all right was I was thinking
do people deserve do women deserve
respect just for being women no no what
what do you so let's go here go around I
know we had some initial reactions but
start here and then go around and say
why I personally think not
um I think women nowadays tend to be
like
very feminist focused you know what I
mean they don't be thinking about the
man which like understandable were women
we think about ourselves that's that's
just life in my opinion
um I think where everything that's going
on in the world and everything that
they're expecting a lot for men a lot of
respect for men when they're not
bringing anything they just think you
know what he has money he's gonna have
me because of what I bring to the table
but what do you bring to the table
absolutely nothing you bring personality
and that's about it that's what I feel
like most of the women nowadays can
bring and women who are out here like
run their own businesses like that like
go for you like I understand that you're
bringing other stuff to the table then
like building Empire together that's
fine no problem but for the women who
don't have stuff like that do you think
men care about if women are building in
together
they don't care about yourself
um but for women I feel like women
really think that men care that they
have to have something you know when
that's not the truth at all okay what do
you think
I see you thinking over there she's like
she's not
um I feel like
try to speak into your mic just you know
I feel like women don't do not deserve
respect off the bat
I feel like you need to earn the respect
um however I feel like a certain level
of respect should be given to you sort
of immediately
um because you cannot respect someone if
they do not respect you
so I then feel like if a man doesn't
give you a certain level of respect you
can't respect him back and there's not
really going to be any respect in that
scenario
and that's all I'm gonna say can I
comment on that yeah do you think that
seedway like you're saying like if a man
can give do you not think it's like the
other way around in general everyone men
and women the respect should be there
straight away yeah if you're focused
with that person more you obviously get
more respect put into you but I feel
like with women it's kind of like why
would I give him respect when he's done
this and you're there would they have
done this Saturday and they're expecting
the respect straight away straight off
the bat and women don't do that most
times
I feel like generally
um women tend to respect men
more sorry women tend to respect men
more than
men tend to respect women off the bat
you think most women respect men
I'm gonna be careful with my words here
because I wouldn't say no more swimming
don't respect that the average guy but I
feel like more women respect men than
men would respect women off the butt
um what makes you say that
I'd say that
it's more like I feel like women need
men more than men sort of need women so
women are willing to give respect
immediately or give trust immediately
rather than the man trying to give it to
the woman because men I feel like men
sort of want to explore different women
so if that's if that's true like why do
we have phrase in society like men are
trash no matter the problem man stupid
man men are dumb men are idiots yeah I
feel but we don't have like you know I
mean well in my space of YouTube women
are [__] is a bit common but in the
general public and media it's it's
really nice and even even on the train
like you'll see um things that are signs
that call men predators on the tube here
as well
um I'd say I think our general society
as a whole right now is failing I think
you can say a lot of women are horse and
a lot of men are trash I feel like we're
in a society now that is favoring like
prostitution like modern prostitution to
the point where it's like women are not
even committed to this guy they just
want this guy for money and this man
wants this girl just because of her body
or her face like people are not actually
loving each other for who they are as a
person anymore do you think that's ever
happened
yeah I feel like the thing is I don't
like generalizing because I feel like
everyone's different
so I I feel like these relationships out
there where they don't care about how
the other person looks they care about
that person as that person like how that
person acts how that person is like how
that person makes them feel some people
just generally want women for status and
for that power what do you think who
do you think that's the majority
I would agree with you on status I don't
know about power I wouldn't say majority
um but I'd say I probably say more I
wouldn't say high value men but men that
perceive themselves as high value would
rather have a woman of
sort of higher
status or I wouldn't say status I
probably think status isn't the right
word but are you still gonna say that
you would say the majority of women
respect most men or respect more men
than men do women because that was the
initial question yeah
um
that I asked not the general again I
think I maybe might have really I'm not
a phrase that a bit wrong I feel like
women seek out men
like need men more than men would say
they need women yeah I think that's sort
of what I was trying to say there okay
go ahead okay so just to restate because
we didn't rip down on a rabbit hut a
little bit yeah
um do do women deserve respect just for
being women correct okay so
um I think yes not just because they're
women though but because we should all
give a basic level of respect to anybody
that we're meeting not because they're
just women or men we should respect each
other period so yes okay what do you
think
um I don't think they should get it just
for being women I think as Lauren said
it's just for being a person
um and you should respect them until
they give you a reason not to respect
them such as maybe they don't respect
their self and don't care themselves in
a great way so maybe your respect level
would go down for them and that's okay
because that's your judgment on them
okay
yeah um respect to me is just is it's
genderless
um you know I think everybody who
deserves a
um you know deserves respect and it's
all about what are you doing to remove
respect off of the actions that you that
you take
okay go ahead
oh I'll tell you the better question is
what what we what we defining as respect
like is it
respect disrespect value like uh that's
why I'm confused that because like see a
dog deserves respect so I don't think
you supposed to just disrespect nobody
but
like what type of respect I guess my
question is more is respect given or is
it earned
well I think it's both you get a basic
level of respect just for being a human
you know what I'm saying for not
disrespecting me like if you don't
disrespect me I'ma respect you because
you're respecting me but if you
disrespect me
Melanie what do you think
um I I think recite the question because
I I like I lost like every women do
women deserve respect for being women no
like because you're born with a vagina
you know like what does that mean like I
mean it's just human anatomy and a lot
of women fight for they say respect me
for my mind respect me for my
accomplishments and we're just as equal
as men but then at the same time they'll
say because I'm a woman
born with the vagina I deserve respect
it's like it's it's a dichotomy it's
like double-minded and it's illogical
like you have to earn respect like if
you are everybody's not going to get the
same level of respect I do think there's
a for human nature yes but I think women
want a respect that they do not give to
men I think respect might be the wrong
word
and now maybe women looking to be valued
I do because you want to be valued just
because you're a woman well I think what
the question is getting at is so many
modern women today that just call
themselves a queen for existing yeah and
you give participation trophies just
based off of you having
okay
which is which is completely trash right
like and I think like you know we have a
society that panders to one gender so
much
um of course it's easy to accept your
your participation trophy for being a
queen but if you were if you were a
queen and you were doing unsavory things
during the night during the street time
activity I think you deserve less
respect for me and to be considering you
within a relationship
what would you define as a queen
what do you mean by Queen when you say
that yeah so like Queen is earned right
like if you think like the concept of
king and queen you know
um you know it is a history within that
um I don't think a queen can be a queen
without a king I think that it is
necessary to have a king first that's
all um and within that um when we live
in a culture of many ish I miss
independent
all of this other all of these other
things that continue to put men down
um and then you meet with the
unrealistic standards of most most
modern women today there just seems to
be a complete like breakdown of society
and the things that are
um important within that so I think a
queen needs to have a king first and
foreign
[Music]
it's almost like we're brainwashed it's
almost like we've been brainwashed to
accept like the the nastiness of us of
society to say okay you're doing you're
you're half naked therefore I like that
and it's just so crazy and it's so
backwards that even dudes like that like
I I used to have guy friends in my life
that would feel like empowered if their
girlfriend wanted to go out and be like
half naked in the club and to me that's
just like it's so crazy because that to
me is not Queen Behavior that's not
marriageable Material
what do you guys think do women I just
think um you have to respond it as a
woman that's my only view on it okay
what do you think I just think if you
don't respect a woman like it has to be
like a good reason behind it and I also
think sometimes if someone doesn't
respect you you don't really care like
you know like if someone doesn't respect
you
their opinion don't maybe believe in the
whole society you should care yeah you
should care everybody without their
boobies out and somebody's gonna say I
don't like you because you're showing
all your front and you're gonna say I
don't care what they say because their
their opinion don't matter that's the
problem with Society because it doesn't
care people don't care what people think
about them you should care if you're out
there and you're acting horish and
you're looking unladylike
and people are coming in and you're
trying to get a certain kind of man and
people are like slagging you off online
you should care turn it down I'm tired
of saying boobies boobies and butts and
fannies and everything's out there I'm
sick and tired of seeing it you also get
to choose who you follow and who you
don't follow on social media too though
so I do think like you know what's up
titties all the time of course and as
far as I'm concerned if you're out there
and like you're saying about the
question was about respect
how do you expect to get respect when
you're out there showing it you might
say oh I don't care but sooner or later
you're going to come to that age where
it's going to hit you and you're going
to care and no one ain't gonna give a
[__] because all your fannies and
titties are out there and they say do
you know what see you on that as well
it's mostly women that will push women
to do only fans and stuff like that as
well like no girl go get that bye go get
this but your man will be like I don't
want you to do it that's why you don't
listen to women that doesn't I 100 agree
one million percent like women will push
you like go queen go do that but at the
end of the day you are losing more
respect for yourself by listening to a
woman telling you to go out and do that
thing that day wouldn't even do
themselves you know what I mean it's
kind of just pushing your morals just a
little bit back you know what I mean I
can't say much more of myself well I do
why do women push other women to do sex
work and um promiscuous activity when
the first thing that happens when a
woman's married she calls another girl a
[__] yeah literally no no and we get so
offended by that word as well when it's
like you don't have one minute because
y'all don't like each other
women don't like each other y'all the
meanest to each other but then get put
off on men oh men say this or do that
like we were talking to this one girl
outside in between the last show she was
talking about getting something done on
her body
and the girl body right she's like it's
already fine I'm saying telling her like
baby you ain't gotta do none of that but
it's not really they're not doing it for
me and they're doing it for other women
you know what I'm saying I don't really
think it's for the women though it's
more for the man because it's a man that
want it no no no no no no no
he was talking about this Society being
brainwashed this Society has been very
much to the point where they think that
is normal and they think that is okay
but but here's the thing I actually
agree with you I think they do do it for
the men but it's like sexual tension
it's not relationship attention so you
can kind of do a cheat code you can go
get a BBL get a nice body and you do get
more attention from men than if you're
flat right but here's the thing though
no no but but listen though but it goes
so deeper though because I know who
you're talking about and he has a great
body yeah so you got to think about how
far down deep that she is within
watching the Instagram models within
watching The Cosmopolitan magazine
doesn't look good to a man and now she
wants to enhance it to look like Betty
Boop you know honestly I think it's
because we're lazy as women we don't
want to go to the gym
I'm just saying if you want to get it
better then you go to the gym as a flat
woman
[Laughter]
I've known you why would you want gonna
get it done because what's her name's
got it done it looks great he must say
yeah it might look good in there but I
don't want that in my bed you know men
want it to look at yeah to um was it
just to add for one night
but they will not marry it they will not
settle down with somebody with a fake or
lips the eyebrows and if they do it
ain't gonna last I think the issue might
be as well that some girls see how other
girls get treated when they get all
these things done so maybe if they get
flown out or good treatment and then
they think when they're not getting
anything they think that they should do
that and then get the attention the
other girls get when actually they're
getting that attention maybe because the
guy is kind of doing something
transactional with them in a way like if
you're flying them out you might expect
something from them yeah and then other
girls want to do that to get the same
treatment women need to be honest to
women because I saw a girl I interviewed
a young lady and I was she had a she had
her butt down another feel I had a good
old feel of it you know and you wouldn't
expect I think
[Laughter]
did it feel good
I wanted to feel their breasts because
their breasts were fantastic
is she here tonight she had the best
breasts I've ever seen ever but when you
think about because the women are out
there and they don't think about the
pain you know the stuff when they get in
their lips it goes rock hard they have
to get it cut out but I looked at her
ass and I thought you've had have you
had your bum down she said yeah and I
said can I have a feel well you just and
I said you've got to say you like and
she said yeah because I had the fat
reduced like taking that beer and put it
in there now women are going to go
around they're gonna go say yeah we've
had that butt done but it was a it
looked like an orange
you know it's just like a ordinary bump
it was nice completely shaped but it was
all it all said he like and I'm sure
that women are thinking about getting
their butt done they're not thinking I'm
gonna get cellulite years ago I used to
get like lip gloss that used to like
Sting your lips and make them swell a
bit now you want to go and get it
injected why can I can I comment on that
right so it's it's this illusion that is
taking place so women to your point want
to do it because of the reactions they
see they're getting from men but at the
end of the day it's so much deeper than
that because their mindset is so twisted
and warped and their value is placed in
this is what I bring to the table and
this is what I need to get and so I can
go get a quick fix if I get my body done
I can go ahead and get you know my boobs
done my buddy my booty done and my lips
done and I'm gonna be able to pull this
attention from a guy not knowing that
that is not lasting that's not the
attention that you want he's not looking
for a wife in that and so by the time
you're in that position you have to
maintain it right so you are looking at
your competition for the girl who
influenced you in the first place to get
that done because now she has become
your competition because your mindset
delusionally you wanted the attention
that she got but in turn of that she's
become your competition and now you have
to compete with her and maintain it and
go get more injections and get a little
poke of Botox over and over when instead
of working on your character and going
and getting healing and doing the
internal work that has gone long term
make you wife material you became an
objective object for him well I think
that the issue is is that modern women
today don't want to be wife material
being white material is not cool for the
majority of them yeah that's very
submissive for women nowadays
yeah okay because at the end of the day
you know whether or not you would get
something done with your body you should
say what are the results that I want in
life what are the results because men
have been telling you that getting
something done to that degree in that
extent does not make you more marriage
immaterial but you would rather be happy
about us though but that's what I'm not
listening to us but then I said yeah
exactly they're not listening to us but
you would rather pay for the short-term
attention validation that you see your
home girls getting versus putting the
actual work in that guy say that they're
actually looking forward to get the end
result that you inevitably want so you
want to get your body done in order to
receive more eggplants inside of you or
do you want to work on becoming more
much more marriageable material to get a
man that is going to provide protect
for you into the long term men change
their minds a lot as well about the body
preference before it was really Slim
girls with big boobs then it was the
massive bums and now men like just
natural
it's a society
what is deep down inside of you has
never changed what the men want well
no because it's been the same all over
the years the what the men has want has
never changed your body might change but
deep inside what the men want has never
changed you keep on changing the outside
when they may not give a [__] about
their eyes they won't keep us they want
to keep they want the inside to say the
same they want the inside like what
their granny had their great granny had
that is the kind of woman they want they
don't really give a [__] about what you
look like outside so you might be
keeping up with the fashion but they
don't care they want the old school the
inside so me you might not never your
big old titties and your age and your
big old ass but I can catch you around
with my flat breasts and my flat ass why
because I and cook clean and I'm
submissive and I can look I think you're
very lucky
it's not luck don't care no it is
because a lot it pisses me off when
people say look I didn't get like this
because of luck this is who I am this is
not bringing from man this is not
listening to stupid women this is
listening to older men older women that
support me this ain't got nothing to do
with luck this is doing hard work and
determination I'm not gonna paying your
money to get your outside fixed up when
you need to pay your money to get your
inside fixture
inside not outside
she dehydrated now that was a lie come
on
it's a great question question for the
panel do you guys think that sex work is
immoral
um
so I I done an only fans but it wasn't
like vagina boobs it was lingerie yeah
boobs were whatever I'd done it and when
I finished it I felt very degraded I
felt very like why did I actually do
that now I know there's girls out there
who do that they don't feel that way
that is perfectly fine you do you you
feel the way you feel but me personally
like like in the future how like when I
have kids and all in the future and if
my kids found out about that they'll
probably get bullied in school there are
people like oh your mom doing this your
mom doing that and your man as well he's
not coming if you don't respect yourself
and you're selling your body online I
can't speak for everyone I can just
speak for myself if you're selling your
body online like that there's not
there's not a high respect for yourself
why expect that from others then you
know what I mean and it's like if you're
doing that sex work it's so different
for you how much money did you make into
so I basically done it like
consecutively for like a week like
literally I posted for the first week in
total first week I made about two
thousand that was from people being nosy
and from people
and first week in one week
if you've seen the stuff that people
would ask you and even outside of it
even to this day I don't do it anymore
but people still being like me oh well
you used to have only fans like what was
that like you you must be real freak no
why are you doing for what they talking
about it's because I wasn't posting this
whole vagina I wasn't doing the whole
thing you know what I mean so you won
you ain't show no none and you know I
showed the titties I showed the titties
but I didn't I didn't show nothing else
you know what I mean and it was kind of
still a point where it's like
I thought I could do that when I got
onto it do you think she won money but
she didn't win respect
do you think that you should be judged
for doing sex work
to an extent it don't I don't care what
anybody says in my opinion it does
speak a lot about yourself it does it
100 even for me like when I done a
people knew the type of girl I was like
I'm very out there I'm open I don't care
I'll speak what I speak and say what I
say and do what I do but when I done it
I just didn't expect to beg like wolf
what did you expect
were you thinking before you did it
before I did it I was like get me get
the bag get the money just get some
money see well was there someone that
influenced you to do it oh yeah I see
all these girls doing and getting the
money but the one thing Instagram Tick
Tock some girls I know and I'm like girl
get it if that's what you want to do
that is perfectly fine like do you me
personally I couldn't do it like that do
you understand if a guy would disqualify
you in the future for that that was the
first thing I said I can understand how
a man would look at me and why why do
you think that you accept that where
other girls will call the man
misogynistic feelings they're not using
their logic they're like how dare you
speak about me like that and it's like
you're taking it so personal I was like
you obviously must feel a specific way
about yourself if data you're speaking
about man a man being misogynistic
because he won't take you up for that
that that's about your own respect
levels and that's that's just your own
opinion like do you do you guys think
that sex work is immoral
um
speak into your mic just you know I
don't forget to an extent yes
um a lot of points that you mentioned
I'd agree with I feel like it comes off
very
desperate and
I just don't generally feel like
um doing them sort of things
don't make you seem like a very good
person
in the way of so it's not your fault
like I'm not blaming you for it how is
it not your fault
whose fault is it I think I think
genuinely like I feel like obviously I'm
not gonna put the blame on everyone else
I thought I believe everyone should take
accountability for their actions and
whatnot but I feel like upbringing
and the like Financial State you're in
yeah but you can't influence you a lot
with them sort of things but you can
look at someone that's born in the same
upbringing they don't make those
decisions yeah no books 100 100
[Music]
um
I feel like they
even just being born in this Century
you're richer than most people were in
all of human history that's true I agree
with that I just feel like because again
going on back onto the part of the
society that we're in now obviously back
in the day it was prostitution that was
looked down upon more now only fans is
being favored especially by like men and
whatnot like men that start only fans
um they get favored they're like all
right he's he's doing his thing like his
[__] different [__] every night
type Vibe it's like it gets favored and
it's normalized to the point where you
think men make more money on only fans
than women
um I don't know the statistics so I
won't speak on that but um obviously I
know I I personally know men that are on
only fans and they do make money like
what's make money as in like they make
how much a substantial amount of
probably like 30k a month so like it is
a thing obviously it's not as normal as
women doing it but it is a thing it's
crazy how men were the ones that kind of
that kind of run the porn society and
it's the women that are falling into it
oh sorry corn Society my apologies how
do they run the corn societies but
obviously women being consumers as it is
we're going to be the ones to jump into
it more you know what I mean compared to
men yeah okay so what do you think
um is sex work immoral yes I absolutely
think so for any sex it doesn't even
matter male or female we weren't made to
do that right like um even just the fact
that we have to wear clothes and layers
is to protect right so even before you
put on your regular clothes you have on
undergarments right and so that in and
of itself just shows the default nature
of how that's supposed to be more sacred
it's supposed to be more private more
secure right we even refer to it as
private parts private areas so
absolutely it's a moral to just be
flaunting that and giving it to anyone
what about you
um so for myself I would say it would be
immoral for me but I I don't know like I
think
is morality different is morality
different for different people like if I
steal and you steal it's different
General nigh but I think some people
will kind of rationalize what they're
doing and then say that they have their
reasons for it and then I'm not I don't
know their lives so I don't know what
their reasons would be but if I still
because I'm hungry does that does that
make it different it's not okay but
people are gonna do what they're gonna
do so if they do it nobody I'm asking if
you think it's moral no I've not for me
I wouldn't no but for everyone do you
think it's moral no no okay okay thank
you all right go ahead hell no and I and
I think like now
um you know I also think as I get older
like if I had a daughter what would my
answer be right like I think it's you
know just think about that but also too
like I think the word the terminology
sex work is it's it's a really like
large term there's a lot of things that
could be encompassed within that but I
also think uh sex work you know could be
you know a lot of these Hollywood stars
that you know show up half naked to the
red carpet right like I was looking at
the Oscars and and Sierra just showed up
to the Oscars uh like literally half
naked and she has two or three kids and
is married to a a a multi
multi-millionaire Russell Wilson that to
me is a component of sex work as well
because she's taking degrees of her
sexuality putting it somewhere and and
going to get brand deals because of it
right like and everything that comes
from it right so like I even think when
we talk about sex worker the definition
has to be expanded for modern times
today because although she's not doing
that and getting direct money or maybe
that she is from the outfit that she's
wearing she could be right but then also
what comes of that right and if there's
an exchange of money then that's sex
work as well
uh I don't know me I don't know my my
thought was on the different everybody
else I don't I don't really see nothing
wrong with it
because like
since we're been going on since the
beginning of time it's never gonna stop
have you ever had a problem no I don't I
don't I don't buy I don't do that but
I'm just saying it's gonna happen like
women gonna get money they're gonna use
what they got to get money men gonna do
the same thing see I'm like torn on it
because on one hand
I sometimes agree with you like I
sometimes think it's needed in a society
because
what are the one in three men gonna do
and if you if you think sex is a need
which it sort of is for men
but then that just makes my stomach turn
to say that too
[Music]
let me ask you let me ask you something
who you think has six more
a regular girl
or somebody who do only fans like who
got one person one person who they sleep
with the only fan they do only thing who
you think regular girl I would agree who
you think having sex mode or a stripper
versus just a regular girl
no I think it's the I think girls that
do promiscuous Behavior are like tend to
make more promiscuous like choices like
I think if someone does that they're
probably more likely to sleep around
that's my opinion I know some people
will say no but I would be able to do I
I'm I would really be able to do because
I'm with you I don't know why I'm always
with you but I'm with you
um
we've been close with this triple or
kind of see what they what they do like
they schedule how they work
damn really yeah they they going to the
club doing anything they come home count
up their money get up in the morning go
to the bank deposit them once they ain't
really out here just messing around like
that but it might be another girl who
going to the strip club
just throwing ones on them but they
[__] that night I think yeah I want
girls in the strip club are desensitized
to it right so that they're when you are
stripping for a man and doing that you
have to sell a fantasy to him right you
have to get into this Persona and give
him the dream for the night so he will
give you the money right and so once you
come off of that in your home and you're
with your family or whatever you usually
they have kids that they're taking care
of and they're doing stuff for they're
exhausted they're tired because I just
had to go and pretend to be someone that
I wasn't and I don't even want I'm I'm
disgusted by men to a certain degree
right because I know how creepy they are
they come here and they're their most
vulnerable and nasty and all the stuff
that everyone else is going to look at
you crazy for I have to take it because
you're paying me to take it so I think
they're desensitized to it honestly I
can see your point and then on the other
end
um it's a girl I'm not gonna say her
name but she's super big on only fans
like she she getting like 200 000 a
month on the fan she only she only sleep
with one dude on only fan yeah there's
girls like that as well think about it
she getting money you can't you can't
you don't get more money than her and
she already got a dude who who pleases
her sexually so she not you're not gonna
even go be able to go mess with yeah but
but the question is based on morality
morality is grounded in principles so
then but what would you be okay but what
is morality what are the things that we
do on every on every day for for the for
money but let's say that you had a
daughter as a father you pass on virtues
you you pass on values you pass on
principles you pass on morality
if your daughter is doing that is that
something yeah I'm not gonna agree with
my daughter doing it so then the answer
to the question for you is no I'm not
I'm not gonna I wouldn't agree with my
my daughter or my senior doing a lot of
[__] I do but yeah
okay
baby lead them in the right way and hope
that hope that they grow up and do the
things that you'll be pleased with yeah
I think there's a place for them I think
it's been there for a long time I think
that if you're going to be a sex worker
you should be single you shouldn't
expect no man and there should be a [__]
Island
wait you can just get a ferry over to
[__] Island and you know like was it
called Hit The Box what do they call it
that box thing
I feel like in regular people go to the
island I think that's the city
we should do a reality show I think for
me I think it becomes a Morrowind they
they're looking for they've got children
they've got Partners uh or they expect
to get a man through it and I think that
if you're going to be a sex worker
that's where you're going to be I I want
you to be nothing else and expect to be
a wife you shouldn't be a mom I think if
you're a mother in your your sex worker
you're the only fans I think if you're a
partner and you're doing anything or
anything like that I think of your wife
no but other than that if you're single
you want to go and do it and you're
harming no one go to slow Island and
just having a whole island
as women know I do think now I will say
this and it ain't my place to say this
either but I do think it's a time limit
on it yeah
at a certain point so you old is here
you need to get your at the streets
after that that's what I'm saying stay
on the island because once you've
started you can't be 30.
there's women out there oh someone it
depends it depends how bad that she is
have you seen that there was an article
about like an 80 year old woman on
Tinder guys were still yeah
she'll be like the five dollar special a
scent will always forgive if she bad
enough yeah um I'm curious what do you
guys think is sex work moral immoral um
uh I don't know I I personally think
like I have a lot of friends and a lot
of people so maybe I'm a bit
desensitized to it but I think corn has
been happening for ages I think as
consent in adults you know well corn has
it yeah it's been okay how before
even before like think about it we had
sex with the statues even of naked women
like women have always been kind of
admired for their bodies yes the statues
are the same thing as like not really
but I mean
admiring women for their bodies and like
I don't know I just we don't think
there's a difference between like a
sexual picture and like a beaut because
some of the olders
pictures the other side
um wouldn't it be the same difference
though
whose phone's ringing
um some but some of the older pictures
it's it's supposed to have to move
forward though so I can imagine even sex
back then wasn't how we have sex now you
know we've become more and more uh
modern freaking disgusting
disgusting you know people what people I
think watch corn really early and normal
sex becomes boring and you want to spice
things up and you do more and more
things that maybe didn't happen back in
the day not say that that's right or
wrong it's for everything yeah well yeah
yeah
so to answer the question moral or
immoral I think it's immoral no I just I
think it's moral oh
um so then you think it's immoral I I
don't know each to their own I think
it's each to their own I think if moral
or immoral we gotta
I think if you're single and like you
said Andy said it was moral yeah I think
it is moral as long as it suits your
lifestyle and like she said I think as
long as you don't expect to for everyone
just to accept it and understand I think
it's moral I said Don't expect a man
don't expect anyone to marry you I think
women too actually make sure you're
talking in here sorry you shouldn't have
any children don't expect a man once you
decide on the sex work that's you too
you die get sex work insurance no I'm
not saying that I think I'm saying
that's how it should be because if
somebody knows that this is how you
start you're not you're gonna you're not
gonna get anybody that should be able to
put women off but there's women again
out there say I can go and be only
friends and I can still get a husband I
can then be gonna be only fans I'm not
gonna have my children I can be only
fans no after you know that that is it
you're gonna have to take dick for the
rest of your life
you get the scraps women that go out and
don't do only you don't get high value
around a lot anyone that has sex for
money anybody that isn't anything about
money I'm talking about like just normal
people that when they don't have their
children they go out and they sleep with
loads of people and they don't do only
fans but they still get married and they
still get respected
because we've got not weave because
there's a platform that you're like
showcased on it's highlighted but
there's a lot of women in privacy that
do a lot worse
do you know what it says if you go on
only fans that you have no shame
you think the kids don't mind I mean
kids don't obviously kids don't have
like the same view I mean like mums and
dads like some people just you know
that's but it's still saying I'm putting
my my money before bringing shame to the
family name
depending on what your family view is on
it right but I'm saying what are the
kids get no say in this so it still it
still goes back to I always talk about
this the me me culture where it's me
before the children yeah oh okay well
hopefully the kids will turn out fine
but you know I need this money so I'm
gonna do this now there's a lot of Pawn
Stars with children that are okay as
well foreign
so the way that you talk it's kind of
like in this this um this my truth you
know it just is what it is everyone can
make decisions but at the same time as I
hear it it sounds like people can make
decisions without repercussions or
Consequences and I think that's on a
slippery slope because when we do that
it starts to get away from
accountability and the thing is is like
when you look at generally what men
typically want out of women men
typically do not want women that have
been conquered sufficiently and
especially have done it for money and
especially have put their risk enters up
on the internet but there's also a
massive
misconcept there's a lot of women that
only said boyfriend on
so that
the conception that if you do only found
your easy words it's most of the time
it's actually very opposite to get in
contact with this woman normally you
have to pay up front like you're not con
she's not respond she gets so many DMS a
day she's not going to respond to you
and it's a moral in the way of like
money money money comes first but I'm
saying there's a misconception that just
because a girl does only fans that she's
maybe easy or easy easy access but
that's not what I'm saying it's it's sex
Work men of value if you can if you want
to win the entertainment besides let's
say like a Kanye West what people in
entertainment have women that have done
only fans publicly there's a lot of
people that do Playboy and like maybe
not as um as graphic but they're still
they're still women with children
my memory is terrible so I think it
should be easy if it happens a lot
there's loads five if you would have
asked me to before I could have probably
researched it but no not off the top of
my head no do you guys understand but
I'm saying if this was common if this
was common we should be able to to name
five or at least one two three off the
top of your head I think far too often
when we have these conversations if
women if women's goal is to be with men
then you have to consider what men want
and irrespective of the brand
if she had been involved with that it's
going to deselect a lot of women and
here's the thing there's a lot of women
are sitting in situationships that think
they're in good standing with the man
but the man just don't say ish yeah but
they continue they continue in that
situationship and just don't don't tell
her the truth or it's fine while it's
still extracting and then as soon as
things while still extracting their
insides so they're getting what they
want and that they already know there's
going to be an expiration date at the
end of it yeah so the thing is is what
is your goal and how how are you working
towards your goal what are the actions
that you're putting in the place and I
think if we if it's on a slippery slope
where you're not understanding what men
want and if the result is a man that you
have to make some changes within the way
that you move within that well I think
it's obviously it started the only fans
she's not talking about getting married
that's the last thing on my mind exactly
that's not what she trying to do until
time Runs Out fantastic yeah and then
she has to think about something have
you ever thought about it or considered
it or done it only fan
um or stripping no because you just seem
really like part of you like you're in
the circle you know I have a lot of I
have a lot of close friends that do it
and I can understand
um and even being a photographer that
does laundry and I I promote body
positivity so I post myself in laundry
and why my content I'm plus size I try
to like I mean so it's not it's not
exactly that but like it's kind of
within a tiny bit of a window with it
you go further
um do you think you're gonna start there
now and you're gonna get so body
positivity you're gonna get so positive
about your body you're gonna think you
know what my friends are doing it I can
go and be positive on only fans that get
paid for it it's like a dominoes if I
did
I would understand the repercussions do
I mean okay it just sounds like you're
you're already invested in that whole
yeah I just think I don't know I just
think some like there's a bit of an
unfair Vision on it sometimes but I
understand why do you know what I mean
but it's like when you're arguing it's
kind of like do I want a thief in my
house no right yeah it doesn't matter if
you know maybe maybe that maybe that
Thief stole five dollars worth of stuff
and that Thief stole 50 but they're
still both thieves and that's what I'm
saying with the guys the way the guys
think about promiscuity okay maybe maybe
the regular girl's worst that's not in
sex work but then guys don't want either
hmm can I just say that if you're
speaking about regular girls to do it
they're not actually putting out there
so you wouldn't know what they're doing
anyway and also saying that girls that
are in sex work might not do it as
regular as a regular girl but maybe they
haven't actually been given the
opportunity if they're trying to make
money off it so who like sex workers if
you're saying that they do it
um less than a regular girl oh
to your point you said like sometimes
regular girls do it more than a sex
worker but maybe the sex workers
if you move around uh we know it goes
from groups after group for sure boys no
boys boys know that like if you think
that you're private and you've had sex
with say 20 boys and they don't know
each other they know men know 100
percent we call that the whole facts
all right let's let's see me you first
started talking they just haven't been
given the opportunity to do that because
they're wanting money from it so it's
like if they got 20 like guys a week
then I'll give you this would they do it
and then be worse with the regular girl
because I was actually getting paid for
it whereas a lot of guys will be as soon
as they find our girl wants money for it
they're not going to do it because why
would I give you money when I can get it
for free and a lot of men argue sorry
that oh I wouldn't subscribe to an only
fans because I have girls that send it
to me for free so the actual nudes and
the spreading and all that stuff isn't
the issue it is the money part
lingo
while I'm in Atlanta
we feel like a girl been around and we
know she's been around we say she burnt
out you know what I'm saying now if you
own only fans or if you're not on the
fans you can still be burnt out is
way we could tell we can tell about how
you how we how you move you know what
I'm saying so let's say me and you first
started dealing with each other well I
don't know you we just talking with
Divine cool whatever
I'm gonna take you to the club let's go
to the club let's go to a spot where
everybody be at
when we walk in this spot I can I can
tell about how you move around in this
spot and who let me in here know you and
I could just I can look at how you
acting until how you move and whether
you burned out or not so it ain't got
nothing to do only fast they got nothing
to do with it none of that is about how
you really moving out here and man gonna
know we're gonna know are y'all not good
enough to hide this [__] you know like a
lot of girls that go to the club
you they might not actually do it
whereas you will meet a lot of like home
bodies for example that they're always
at home but a man's always with them
like and it don't have to be the same
man it could just be different man you
wouldn't know because if someone feels
ashamed about it or anything they're not
going to tell you they'll just lie so
you will never know really what goes on
in someone's life unless you've got
proof I always hear from guys that like
women always tell on themselves that a
girl can fool you but only for so long
do you guys think that's true yeah for
sure you're gonna know like maybe not at
first like I feel like it's like maybe
not at first but if you do enough
someone's gonna talk and so you might
you might see other quiet girl at the
party or whatever but then you know you
get to know her a little better you see
who's around her and someone's you know
a seated as you living in now if you're
going to a fresh City and don't nobody
know you Ronnie
we played football in London we we
graduated from London we went to college
we went to different colleges around
here
when I get to bringing you around yeah
somebody gonna edit my old words man hey
oh you [__] was shouting man shout it
hard man shout out bro baby for real
you're gonna let me know what's going on
that's just how they go
um do you guys think it's hypocritical
for men to consume corn while shaming
sex workers
yes yes yes yes yes big yes yes yes
all men watch more so it is
corn because the amount of men that can
get sex compared to women that's why men
watch corn it's it's the fantasy of oh I
wish I could have this or I feel like I
want to have this but they can't get a
comparative amount of women would you
not think so would you think that's why
I think that's why I think man sometimes
we don't feel like we don't feel like
doing all it required to to go have sex
y'all so instead of sometimes one
calling y'all dealing with y'all picking
y'all up spending money finding
somewhere to take y'all doing this then
the third and still might not get no
crucial I just I just do it and be done
with it now my mind clear I can go back
to normal I just think men are horny so
we'll be horny yeah it just it just is
an easy accessible thing to get nowadays
you got some girls you like man I need
that I gotta have it so I'm gonna go
through this I saw you shaking your head
I saw you thinking yeah hypocritical or
no yeah um no it definitely is but I
think a lot of dudes are making a a
rational decision uh because it you know
to get ready for a date you know there's
a lot of things that you got to be able
to do right so like you know whether or
not it's um you know you're busy on a
Friday night you might just do that real
quick get it out the way you could get
back to your utility you know working on
your purpose you know if you got a lot
of work to do so yeah it could be
hypocritical but like you know I know
you said 100 of dudes watch watch corn I
I don't you know I I make my own and
watch myself okay
is it hypocritical yes or no
for men to watch corn but shame sex
workers
it's a bit critical but it's
understandable
because they've heard the woman that was
giving it to him they wouldn't have to
watch it
so they need to add it somewhere
otherwise that's when he's not talking
about was it in sales I found out the
other day that word so
corn prevents in cells at least they're
getting some
you know sometimes you need to get that
off of your body like like you know what
I'm saying you just need to get it off
for you build up stuff right like I'm
more for making your own I won't be
making your own I really is there like
any studies that go over like the rate
the rate of
um are decreasing as Hub has increased I
don't know that would be so interesting
yeah
that would be oh look it up yeah do you
want to tell me um
what was the question again do you think
it's hypocritical for a man to shame sex
workers but watch corn I think that
a lot of men pretend respect women
so just as women not all not all but I'm
saying in in some in the sex industry
especially a man might pretend to
respect what you do I've had it before
um in the sense of like a man would be
like I respect what you do at like big
big up yeah
because they won't put us in as soon as
they know that sex is not on the table
it's like like how do you expect anyone
to respect you yeah exactly modern women
today and I respect you and you'll be um
but it depends what you're talking about
like I said I'm my and what I've just
said me is just me posting myself in
laundry so if you if you say that's me
being a hoe then that's your opinion
yeah okay I respect you and you still be
a whole at the same time can two things
be true yeah um it I think it's down to
what what you respect I think it's okay
I respect you what do you call it and
you'll be a hoe at the same time you
gotta answer that for yourself I mean
yeah yeah
this is how we started off right the
podcast what is respect and it's like
all people at a basic level deserve
respect right so what level are you
trying to respect this hoe right like
take it there are you trying to respect
her as a wife then no are you respecting
her because you met her on the street
and we're having a conversation yes I
can respect you I can respect the buff
it's not based off of that respect isn't
basic respect isn't given off of that
right so to your basic question in
general context can I respect the Hope
Yes
Y'all gotta start acting like two things
can't be true I think that respect is
earned I think there's a basic level of
like kindness that you should treat
people with
I feel like respect is earned at the end
of the day
she had on such an important point over
here though is the idea that men are
lying for the for the sleeves
[Music]
modern women today are mostly out of
line due to simps and white Knights yes
dudes just trying to do things in order
to get the butt there's nothing more
disgusting than a male feminist it
disgusts me it disgusts me because
you're putting yourself in a place in
order to increase the chance of being
with one of these women like she ain't
gonna [__] you bro
smashed so much because it's the man
it's it's the male feminist the early is
women to speak speak on like this is why
men are still so oppressed because it's
women being out here and it's like oh
well you can't have this like you just
want the [__] boy it's like you're
gonna give them the [__] anyways but
don't you see
um women only fans as business women
especially if maybe because somebody's
in business somebody business but I mean
like do not respect them as business
women especially
you know why
your [__] open on because
you know honestly there's one
bad Barbie okay the bad baby baby is
that what it is
like I'm gonna give it to her I'm gonna
give the 99 of them know but we don't
actually make 50 million off of like
fully clothes
you see what she said she only done it
as soon as she's only gone 18 is it is
that what it is and she said she only
said this year she thinks it's so
um what was the word she think it's
despicable the amount of men who
subscribed to her only found the
students
yeah
horrible I think he's gross nasty I
don't I don't even care if his lingerie
no offense it's just not my thing but
that's a lot of money that's impressive
yeah that's what I'm saying is there is
there a figure on money that would make
you respect
wait wait I don't think respect is the
right word I just think it as a business
okay do you respect a cartel boss he
makes billions of dollars
but right like just because they make a
lot of money does money
no absolutely not money the love of
money is the root of all evil and so a
lot of women are selling their bodies
and their souls you have to go to sleep
at night and I'm sorry you're busting it
open and at some point like if if money
equal self-respect and respect there's
people who are billionaires that delete
themselves like these women have to go
to sleep at night how many how many
women have we seen Instagram models
right now I want any woman to think who
are the Instagram models busting it open
that are getting married that are men
respecting and wifing up no they're
getting flown to Dubai to get busted
down for a camel and to get uh defecated
in the mouth oh wow
no no I mean we're speaking uh
scientific language here okay so
there's documentaries these women are
doing this and and like I don't care how
much I would rather be homeless and
destitute than not to be able to sleep
at night knowing the things that I've
had to do now there's one thing if
you've been violating this against your
will okay that's one thing and there's a
lot of women whose mind has been warped
because things have been done against
them against their will but that's not
the majority a lot of these women have a
love of money and they don't give a damn
what it means to anybody because money
is the only thing they want to buy bags
are they getting this money because they
want to build wells in Africa
and then they wanted no they're [__]
and the point is there is no respect
because you know what you're doing my
daughters see this that you you are
against wives you're against the women
who have put in the work to earn a
family tradition you have to earn a
family and so if you are a [__] in the
street and you're busting it down open
and only fans you are the enemy of women
who are traditional and I'm sorry there
is no love in the just like you have no
love for me because you're going to bust
bust it open for my man and if a dollar
is going to pull you in that's all
you're worth is money you have no
intrinsic value like you there like you
have no morality you you don't believe
in anything but what you you can buy
Gucci and and whatever like I'm I'm
sorry there is no respect for that and I
don't mean it in a way to understand
women make decisions where they are but
at the same time somebody has to stand
up for Savannah James
LeBron James wife when she was on that
run on the Oscars you know you know she
she had she had two children out of
wedlock with LeBron James as as a
teenager her sons
but she made a different decision not to
go you know she stuck with a man and and
she made a different decision like there
are like who stands up for women who are
trying to do it right and right now I
feel like the dominant voice and culture
right now is women who are Horrors you
know don't judge me yes oh I'm judging
you so and I don't care like if you're
opening your your box for the street
like take everything that comes with it
don't demand respect when you don't
respect women you will take you will
entice that woman's husband and you
don't give a good goddamn what happens
to that family and what happens to them
but then you demand women to say respect
all this and other do you respect the
wives that have to deal with the BS that
you're doing and and and you're and then
like just accept being bottom of the
barrel not only do they not respect the
wives but then they call the wives pick
me right right exactly respect the wives
but they want all this respect but a
woman who wants to be a wife
be submissive they want to holler they
talk about Kevin they shame they're
excited Kevin Sams when he died because
they discovered the stuff he talked
about with men and how he tried to get
men together and I and I spoke about it
because he was a personal friend of mine
but you don't respect us but then you
want all this this respect but your
[__] is open for consumption like no
you don't respect a wife you'll be ready
to be a side chick you will take that
man's money you will steal his you will
steal him from his wife you would do
whatever it takes to get a dollar and
because your mind is degraded and your
mind is gone and your mind has been
snatched into hell you're Middle Earth
and what's so crazy is that we have a
culture today period that supports that
like I was just down in Atlanta not too
long ago and there's a restaurant down
there I'm not going to name it because
they don't respond to me but they got
this new sandwich called the side chick
and they got Brittany Renner Brittany
Renner that will come in she'll come
through and she advertises because she's
a side chick football player and people
that know her and they will say and they
don't care Hey listen and they
appropriate come to me and talk to me
about it and just like Brittany Arena
she's a six that's what we don't want
her she tried to get with us after the
podcast and we were just like oh [__]
shots fired yes you know who I'm talking
about too you know
but you know who I'm talking about and
all these women yeah I do actually they
would go ham if they knew who it was and
he was like nah you a six chick I'm I'm
like you got a mouth and you for the
streets I'm done listen but the the
culture it supports it right so like
mainstream media is giving her money to
promote her being a side chick crystals
no we don't talk about that food
restaurants no advertisements crazy
though if a girl gets married at 19
they'll say she's making a terrible
decision and she's two years but she's a
[__] at 45 like Bernice Burgos is a
grandmother and still out there like
look at my booty oh I'm that like if you
that fine and why don't you have a
husband yet like why are you this fine
this you're so special you're so special
but look at these old hoes they're
sitting up and they're still trying to
get money like they are grandmothers now
busting it open for a check you have to
understand you men it's not that you are
less valuable as a human being
but if you are you are putting yourself
in a position men do not respect you as
a way no man of value wants to bring a
known hoe
and as this is my wife and you around
his boys and he's proud of you in
presenting you no you in the back room
he'll date you he'll you know what I'm
saying because you're a known hoen is
like okay we we all skied it and skirted
in this so it's my turn you know says
she was never yours it was just your
turn and so a lot of women I say this
not to degrade a woman but to understand
y'all women do not understand how men
think
they do not respect you and you are
doing this and you think you're earning
something and and you're a bad B because
you make all this money you're going to
die on that hill with all your money by
yourself look at what Cher got to do
right now and I'm not putting share down
because she you know saying she did her
thing but she's having she stole it's
actually more shares value she stole
Amber Rose's man
she is in her 70s and she sold a woman
in her 30s man and and do you know the
embarrassing and she got a forehead
tattoo for that man and share a woman 40
something years older than her snatched
her man go [__] girl bye like like if
Amber if if it's that much why is
Brittany Renner not wife though why is
Amber Rose not wiped up look at him the
old Hollywood stars who are not wiped up
they're beautiful women
they intermedia running their mouth yeah
not only that but they hoes look at
Christina Milian because she she's a
woman
right like there's women who have been a
whole day
but to your point right where are the
wives and media that's not what's
highlighted what's highlighted it's the
Britney reiners are the people who are
selling this lifestyle and these gen Z
babies are eating it up they think that
that's what men want yeah they're sure
but that's why because we aren't being
talked sorry we have no Representatives
did any of you ever as a kid did wait
did any of you ever as a kid want a girl
wait wait did any of you ever as a kid
grow up and want to be a housewife no
yes really you did yes like
even till now I'd want to do like house
like be a housewife but like maybe work
like two days from home or something but
I was gonna say yes and then she had
another extra yes there's Housewives she
didn't say housewife but how many were
raised you won't why were you raised to
be a housewife like I grew up in
southern baptist and submission like a
lot of women think it's dirty I'm like
this is standard model that's like
asking for doors and windows on a car do
you do you feel like you're a race to be
a housewife
um
not like with my dad and things like
that as in I saw that growing up but I
my mum like took me out to cook to clean
and things like that so that's what I'm
comfortable doing and then as you get
older and you realize you do have to
work and you're used to it you think I
would want to bring something to the
table as well like working and
intelligence and things like that but
also still want to but you're a
Housewives for the CEO of your
corporation in the company a lot of
women say I don't want to be a domestic
slave I want to have my own money that
CEO that's your daddy that's your sugar
daddy that's who you shaking it for yes
sir yes your man he's paying everything
for you and you think that's Freedom
when this man don't like they if they
have if they have to make Cuts in the
company you're out they don't care about
you there's nothing about you you're not
valuable and you have to compete in it
is tiresome and you're exhausted your
kids suffer your kids are or buck while
like like I don't think people see the
consequences but I don't blame young
women I think it's a failure of older
women
who we have indoctrinated our younger
younger women you know Maggie and I like
I'm I'm 41 and Maggie is an older woman
I know I blame older women
yeah we did we didn't send like we I I
mean I personally did my mother did in
the women in my family have but I know
in large we have failed these younger
women and we've let them just run the
streets and we have not checked our
daughters I I let me catch my daughter
my mother today if I post a picture at
my age my mother is 74. I am 41. let me
post a picture where the dress is a
little too much short
my mother would text me and say you look
[__]
and I feel shame and embarrassment and I
feel like I failed my family I think
it's a failure of the family structure
my father he doesn't have to say
anything him and I won't talk for days
he's my best friend and I said that like
he's just like Mel like like your mother
told you what like you like and I think
a lot of women have not had the the love
of a family of of men
to to tell them the truth and and that's
why they hated Kevin Samuels because he
was a fatherly figure that told them the
truth and they didn't want to hear it
like your average your average hoe like
and you have whole activity and if you
want to get better you have to do better
but the the Rebellion no one's ever been
in your life to discipline you so it's
like who are you to tell me what to do
because you're you you did never had to
discipline you can't even believe
someone would tell you the truth about
you but there was a love for you and he
wanted you to grow but that's even
that's why they celebrated his death
because now we're free to be hoeing and
nobody's going to hold us accountable
two things because she was looking at me
and calling me Maggie that's why I was
actually laughing oh I'm sorry exactly
because you're my energy you know the
Maggie energy
because I knew she met me but she's like
Maggie I'm Auntie Jenny and the other
thing is um when it comes to old people
about raise the bill I was raised to be
a wife my mom I also my mom get up early
in the morning and do stuff and cook
stuff and even when my mom got divorced
with my dad I still kept it out I
started to go and you know visit my dad
did you make sure dad got his food and I
remember washing his clothes by hand you
know and I I thought you know what I
want to do that I want to be a housewife
because
in in my day you had to wash things by
hand now you've got washing machines
people are making it sounds like it's so
hard
being a housewife's a piece of piss
that's it you you work out your routine
and I've seen women do it where they can
I've improved it to probably know rush
around and make yourself do nothing all
day and you can rush around with all mod
cons you can get that house Tip Top get
everything sorted two hours before you
get some dinner cooked house clean
because you've got all the mod cons so
women to say oh yeah I want to be a
housewife but I want I also want a job I
don't want that job you've got a job the
job is to look after your man your
children the house what more do you want
you've got the car you can go where you
like you can fool the man because what
all he cares is like you know getting
his balls emptied and getting his belly
full I'm gonna do that if I was taking a
picture of their house right now if I
told you right now take a picture of
your house every room in your house I
want to see how it's organized decorated
and I want to see it is it a hot ass
mess is it about is it does it look like
a trap house is it like a crash site is
your mattress on the floor is your it
you're worried about bag but your home
you where you dwell you're in the street
if you you live in the streets if you're
about that life you're not taking care
of a home you don't really care what's
going on in there we've seen these
videos on YouTube and you have to say to
yourself like I'm not making a home like
what man wants to come home
my you know in my home smells ratchet a
lot of women your pH balance
we're going like like and I'm just going
to say this because we're going to be
out here we out here right like we're
talking about sex work
like how many men right now you take
your panties off and they can smell them
uh-oh
shower for a couple days and your
panties still smelling things
that BV is banging why because yeah
vaginosis has passed and I'm not putting
as a shame but a lot of young women your
mothers have not taught you how to even
wash yourself properly douche okay no it
ain't even about you shouldn't even do a
douche like and that's what I want to
talk about that because a lot of young
women have not been taught this and
we've got to have these conversations
your your box is for the street but your
box
take go to the bathroom you take them
off let me as a woman I'll Stand in that
bed I go to the bathroom and I smell you
I come in the bathroom after you and I'm
smelling
[Laughter]
a lot of these women your ass stink
stink and you don't even you think this
is cute you don't wear perfume you think
you just spray some body spray you don't
even know how to clean you're not
hygienic let me tell you something I
ain't got to take a shower for a week
if I chose not to I will I will I listen
listen my mother because if she taught
me you come around my mother and she's
74. she has no body odor from head to
toe she has no body hair
why because she was taught how to be a
woman right now it's about being sexual
but not how to be a actual woman and
have your womb clean your womb has been
ran through it's been it's it's Plan B
it's Planned Parenthood it's been ran
through so many it's so many sticks
inside those walls and I want to say
this in a way not to criticize you but
to understand
you have been degraded by the street the
the street has once your mind gone
they want you ran through with vaginosis
they want you going to the clinic they
want you taking the medication they want
you on Plan B why because because your
mothers have failed you your fathers
have failed you the society has failed
you but there are women like me
like Pearl oxygen no I'm gonna say it
and Maggie The Substitute Teacher where
we say we love you we don't we know
you've been failed and it's not a
judgment on you we want you to win and
we're trying to give you the cheat code
so you don't have to be out here like
these other women and struggle
take this mess off you don't need all
this on you like like like you got your
nails done your wig fixed you got all
this done I go to the bathroom after
your ass stink girl that BB is
bvliet
I want to say two things is that when it
comes to the All stinkiness Size Doesn't
Matter because the skinny [__] is smell
this is better
it does not matter
she smell perfect the young girl the
young lady next to the Irish lady I want
to know it's a joke because she was
there telling us like giving everybody
information and everybody else was
listening and you were killing yourself
laughing I want to know what was so
funny because I didn't get the jokes I'm
just a giggler no but I've just found a
little bit of it funny that's all so she
was she was talking you were just
rolling around giggling for no reason
um could you tell me specifics and I
could probably remember I'm talking
about
he calls you to be sterile because
Brittany Renner talked about how she
took she had three men down in one week
and she had a nasty yeast infection
had chlamydia and you had gonorrhea
let's not call it no it's not nice I
don't care what's nice
I'm not saying it's not nice if you
busting it open and you taking three
dicks down like let's be adults like
there's nothing nice about you taking
three days
obviously you can catch BV without
having sex you can cash five after cab
stop the cat you can't stop that I know
you can but y'all are taking down like
I've never been seen in the world before
BV was never this important because
women had a man and they were not
running the streets y'all got yeast
infections running up the streets like I
said I will take and I'm not trying to
be nasty but we can go to the bathroom
right now let's do it oh
yeah
[Music]
no if we're talking about sex worker
we're gonna go that raw I feel like I
have to speak in that way and I don't
say it to put you down but understand
you have been failed as a woman as a
young woman your mother has failed you
you you are you you ran through your
walls are ran through and bust through
and you are dealing with diseases and
everything else and you're dealing with
infections
and and when I go to the bathroom after
a young woman and your ass stink right
like I'm sorry like you I should never
go to the toilet I go to any restroom
right now I go to the mall
and your butts stink
that is up to judgment
now I'm not saying you but you can't
judge if you're at like like we are and
I'm just telling I'm just like good God
girl what is going on like and I say
that because who was your mama that did
not have you keeping yourself clean as a
woman guys I want the men to tell me
it's personal hygiene and smell of a
woman priority
is that she can be the baddest yeah most
women get ghosts and her it's a
non-negotiation it is nasty it it is
some stink down there non-negotiable but
a lot of young women they don't know how
to clean themselves I I have preteen
daughters I have to get behind them like
do not play with me you were taking two
three showers a day a bath
soak I don't play those games how many
mothers in here say you putting you get
in the bath Epsom salt we putting a
little vinegar in there we're doing
whatever we have you will not walk out
this house without your deodorant
without being cleanly shaved without
having your body in order a lot of us
because our mothers were struggling
working whatever we were left to figure
it out on our own we go to YouTube and
find out vaginal care
but you're ready to bust it open on on
only fans and your box stank
so what would you say to people that
obviously
didn't have a very good figure growing
up but maybe they didn't get taught the
things I don't necessarily think it's
their fault yeah yeah they should have
taught themselves
what you say in hygiene and whatnot but
what if you grew up in a way that you
wasn't taught these things and again
it's not necessarily your fault but
you've had to learn yourself and you're
being judged for that okay is that young
lady a virgin who you
um I'd prefer not to answer that
question who taught you how to have sex
what I was going to say was that you get
to an age when you're an adult and now
you're saying oh this person hasn't
taught me that that person I'm not
saying that personally for me
I have twerking classes but you don't
know how to clean clean your vags yeah
no that's that's true I'm just being
devil
is there for everybody to learn unless
you pick up something
let's put a tender hand on it let's put
a tender hand on it we got fire and it's
not to anyone in this room
but what it is is we are upset with how
Society has brainwashed you
because we believe in all of you being
beautiful and we feel like they have
tried to brainwash you into something
that you were not never meant to be and
we feel like you've been failed and we
have to come hard because Society comes
hard at you and tries to tell you who to
be and we want you to win we want you to
be wise we want you to not have to be
out here selling and opening your
vaginal walls in order to make a dollar
that is a failure of your parents that
is a failure of society that is a
failure of your education and is a
failure of who you are more in your
morals it's a failure but guess what but
once you acknowledge that we all have to
come to a place of failure men have to
do it every day men are told they ain't
ish men are told if you're broken Dusty
we don't want no scrubs if you're short
if you're this body positivity only
exists for women yeah where is the men
on the cover of of Cosmo and all these
magazines so men are used to these hard
talks so if you haven't been raised
around men my father you know he didn't
call me Princess he didn't call me queen
he didn't call me beautiful when I was
born as a baby I was I was a little
chubby thing he called me meatball I was
a meatball As I Grew it went from
meatball to meat
and meaty and big meaty and fat meaty to
this day my father's like what's up fat
meaty and he would tell me when my
thighs was looking extra thick and he
said you ain't like that you got a
little extra look at that but he would
say it in a way and he trained me in a
way to to say or if I if if I didn't put
deodorant on that day and my father said
like my father would tell me you stank
guys if I put my underwear on the floor
in the bathroom my father would tell my
mother you better get that girl or if I
left the bathroom and my butt stink my
father would tell my mother you better
put her in the tub well because back
then they cared about shame but now it's
like we live in this culture that's so
woke that you can't shame free you can't
shame anyone for anything some of the
best things that's ever happened to me
in my life is because someone shamed me
and it is it's not about shame to put
you down like shame is about you know
what wow like what I thought there I
have been shamed about many things
and I only say this because I want you
to win like this isn't to put you down
is to give you a cheat code of what men
want all these women will call me a pick
me they think I'm pandering to men no I
am who I am and if men choose me the men
y'all want the Ballers and all of that
they're coming to women who have a sound
mind with clean draws and they and even
older because they they see that and
what we're saying to you is we want to
pick up that torch and I do believe even
my Improvement that I have to do because
I come so hard and I realize it can come
like a freight train that's something I
have to improve I have to hear if you
guys give me feedback say if you said it
this way I I could receive it better
so I even will say even here live like I
am I need to be accountable can I come
better in my Approach yes I absolutely
I'm a work in progress so the day I take
my last breath but I say it's not out of
hate for you I hate what has happened to
you has has deceived you because I think
I think every woman on this panel today
is beautiful and has like unique
features and it has something to offer
and to can win and to find happiness but
can every woman here today say would you
be happy doing only fans would you be
happy having to sell and show your body
or would you want a man who loves you
nurtures you protects you or men around
you who say this is a valuable like
don't play with her like that's that's
that's our like like you don't like you
can mess with these chicks over here but
that's Wifey right here we don't you
don't you don't do that like over here
with her and that's how men treat me
even at my age having two children at 41
like it I I'm protected so I don't ever
say does a man protect and provide of
course that's all I've ever experienced
even been through divorce
foreign
I'm just curious we have a variety of
Ages on the panel what do you think the
average body count is for someone your
age and just you know we're not saying
this is your body count anyway just
based on stories you've heard people you
know around you say your age first and
what you would guess the average body
count is
I'm 25 I'd guess the average body count
for around for a woman sorry for a woman
at the age of 25
and the society you were in I'm gonna
say like an average like
60 and 17 but that's just for like what
I know and what I've been about that's
all I can say you would say 16 17.
that's all I can yeah
um I'm 21 and I'd say average I think
it's important to say in the western
culture in the west yeah yeah um
I think it'd probably be around 12 to 20
12 to 20 yeah for 21 yeah okay
especially someone not being at Uni or
whatnot wow yeah I like genuinely yes
okay
I am 33 and I think the average body
count is
25 30.
okay complete guess
so I'm 23 and I'd say the same as Aisha
probably like 15 to 20 15 to 20 what
would you say I'm 55 I was gonna say 10.
I was doubling numbers I was thinking
but if it's five for me it must be 10
for everybody else I think about 10 or
55. and so you would say um women your
age that are married or single would you
say the same yeah 10. yeah okay what do
you guys think I'm a Grandma Bonnie how
old are you I'm 30. and you would say 10
say about 10. I'm 26 and I'd say 15 to
20 15 to 20. I'm curious from the guys
what do you guys think it is
say your age first we'll go through yeah
I'm uh 37 and I I would say it's
probably around 20.
for 25 year old women
all 26 ish oh
I don't know man it depends out the girl
I'm thinking about right now you're a
freak you're free
now you gotta think about it you say
about 50.
how many bodies does it take for a girl
to become a hoe
oh I think I I genuinely think if if
you're
I'm gonna say 10 I do think 10 in a
specific age range okay so 10 by how
what age 10 by 24 100 if you're starting
at the bear rage so what about what
about 30 at 10 does she
I don't know because I think like women
especially like being 30 yeah I think an
amount of like situationships
relationships dates that go on over a
few months I'm just curious where it's
where it switches so at 30 like how many
bodies is she a hoe oh damn 24 10 ho
okay 30 what is it
20 to 30 20. okay go ahead
um
how many bodies does it take for a girl
to become a hoe
um
uh is I think I think it's very
complicated because there's different
scenarios in which the woman could have
had sexual intercourse okay what are the
scenarios like for example if you uh
yeah speaking of what are the most sorry
if you had like a lot of like one-night
stands and whatnot obviously I think
that is quite hoar-ish but if a woman
genuinely got tricked by like quite a
few guys into thinking that she was
gonna end up in a relationship by this
guy so then she sort of have you been
naive and have sex with him how many how
many how many how many times does a girl
have to have sex with someone for it to
not be naivety anymore so you know do
you mean like one person
so you have sex with one guy let's say
right he tricks you okay Bamboozled you
thought you're gonna get into a
relationship he says baby it's you you
have sex it's in fact not you then you
do it again the guy says baby it's you
you have sex with him he says in fact it
is not you then there's a third guy he
says baby baby baby
it was still not two so then the fourth
guy comes around okay and you know I've
never heard anyone when I asked this
question I've never heard anyone say
four so so far four like men are okay
with right so the fourth guy comes
around he says Baby It's You but then in
fact was not you again yeah how many
times like were you naive and how many
times were you just making a choice I
don't know again I think depending on
age
um again it varies but I think anything
more than like double digits could be
considered a whole okay and by what age
roughly
um
let's say about my age I think even
double digits after my age I think you
said you're 21 yeah okay 21 10 okay fair
agree double digits by 20s
it's questionable
go ahead I agree but also
for myself as well I think it kind of is
based on how you present yourself
because if you was like Loki and nobody
knew anything about you how would anyone
be able to call you a hire whereas if
you're out displaying your business and
you could have maybe had sex with one
person then people might call you home
from the way you're presenting it well
then then you would just be a secret
hell yeah
but I
but I'm act for you what do you think I
agree with what they said but I just
think roughly 10 by 20s yeah okay you're
hitting double digits then I'm gonna get
the answer from the girls and then we're
gonna go to the guys so Auntie Jenny
I think five by 25 otherwise you're
gonna be a leftover I think five by
twenty five I'll pay any number that
stops the man from one in your Marion is
too high
so I think that it shouldn't be women
that decided a high number I think it
should be men and if a man says five's
too high then five's too high if a man
says two is do I it's like right now men
are saying they want virgins so all
these are wrong
um go ahead I'm just asking each person
I don't teach to their own that's how
I'm asking everyone yeah so I'm not sure
I think as a consent in adult as long as
you're both single I I find the whole
sleeping with people and making you a
hoe I don't really get it but what else
would make you a hoe I think sleeping
with maybe people that are in
relationships or being unsafe like if
you're protecting yourself so like yeah
so if this week I slept with 20 dudes
but but I use condoms I was being safe
right so am I not yeah no I get what you
mean yeah depending on the space I guess
as well like how do I put pants so I'm
asking like what what would quantify how
and what would not so it's probably in
the space of a short period of time a
large number okay so
uh let's say two guys in six months oh
we're not a hoe
no matter how four guys in six months
yeah probably that's a bit wild for
foreign okay what about uh lifetime ten
oh we're not a hoe I don't think that's
a whole no 20 lifetime
lifetime
I'd say 25 let's just say oh then yeah I
mean it's it's questionable so that's
maybe I'm just asking your personal
opinion now with the meant that yeah I
think it's questionable but so 20 is not
it's almost a hoe almost yeah almost
they're not quite there yet Thirty
Thirty
yeah probably 30. okay so 30 is a hoe
okay go ahead I think
because how many times can you get it
wrong but that's my own opinion okay now
men
you go first I went first okay let's
let's say uh 20 25 year old girl what do
you think uh give me 25 and give me 30.
um
I don't know what we 25 I think when you
start hitting friend groups and [__]
like okay you know you know you know I
caught two from this friend group uh two
from this friend group
then you hung around at that point Cause
you gotta think about I see I'm thinking
realistic
okay
when girls gone girls trips
they be that that don't buy discount
when that first week of college when
girls go to college you know I know girl
be wild or not that [__] count so this
20 number that that they give to I I
don't know maybe it's America I don't
know or down south but is that what that
sounds from America I'm from down south
but I never went on a girls trip and
wild out
no Lord himers no men tinked out we get
into college girl yeah
uh
he hits one of you kind of wildling
you're kind of wildling at 25 years old
yeah
a 25 20. yeah and that's 24 years and 24
years and what do you think the average
body count is what did you say earlier
oh you said like 40 or 50 right
for girl yeah I like 30 something like
that or 30 okay 35. okay what do you but
it might not be crazy I don't know
I don't know how okay it's just your
opinion it's not you know he's not fussy
uh MTR God yeah I think I like 20
at like 25
after five to six it's like
how many times you gonna mess this up
how many times girl you don't even have
five or six relationship but they
haven't sent outside of just people who
they in a relationship with everyone's
saying everyone it's crazy well the
thing is like if you okay well the thing
is like at five to six most don't
because like they don't consider it as
mess-ups
right like they don't they don't
consider us lessons yeah like lessons
like oh I learned from that experience
but that lesson [__] right though like
to a degree learn from their mistakes
but Wise Women mature women five high
achieving women
are gonna learn from others five or six
by the time you 25 and she she only got
five with his body man you man oh you
better keep that that's a good one
I think what like everything nowadays
five or six at the age of 25. do you
know what's that to me is that when
everybody's talking about their numbers
you're not talking about six months that
that's a relationship yeah but see what
I mean it's like what I have people say
one every six months or two in six
months and I'm thinking [__] don't
people have sex like for years you know
that you're having sex for like two
years minimum but now it's like I have
sex on a date I have sex for a week yeah
so a couple of months yeah I'm in a
situationship everybody just wants to be
out there having sex
that's what media is nowadays that's
what it is
you can have sex on your own you don't
need men yeah what is that I have a
really good question which is worse a
girl with five bodies in one year all in
all one night stands or five bodies in
one year all attempts at a relationships
that were two to three months each oh
dot when the second one 100 you're
looking into all the red flags and just
accepting them straight away but you're
not just doing it willy-nilly like I'm
out on a nightclub I'm just gonna go off
with him for the night but you're
actually putting like because women we
we put our trust into men first of all
we're not just going to be like ah no
he's doing nothing whatever you're
putting your trust into these men over
these six months
learn from it you're not learning from
it I just agree I'm gonna go on the
other end I'm gonna say the five one
night stands because to me that's
borderline you might as well be a sex
worker get paid for your work at least
you're out here giving volunteer away
just what you doing just
yeah actually I thought this question
was gonna be different I read it wrong I
think this is actually a pretty easy
answer
um okay I'm gonna read the super chats
really quick uh make sure you guys like
the video guys
um a like is the most important metric
that YouTube uses to push out these
streams so uh make sure you like the
video also guys all Super Chat blessing
what are we saving for right now what do
you blessing is always bleeding me dry
how do we how do we have one of the best
sets on YouTube I do have the best
producer in the game I will say a
blessing is phenomenal he is so smart
but he does bleed me dry so please send
donations for what do you want blessing
I'm trying to go to the USA we need that
Visa money
yeah guys we are we are our goal is to
move you know we Face some
discrimination in this apartment complex
I'm not going to get too much into it
um but you know they've been causing us
some issues so we have to look at other
options you know we may be moving to the
US in the fall so all donations help so
we can do that because it is going to be
very expensive when we do move
um we may leave an office here I don't
know depends on how we're doing so you
know send donations anyways
John Crowder thank you for the Super
Chat black is Panther
um I read your question earlier Robert
Harold if your body count is higher than
your age you should chill
um feelings monogamy says more than one
light water FTR
um ft I think MTR men think you're a 304
after two
um Lord's honesty comedy someone must be
really someone must have had someone
must have had a really fishy scent Mel
is pissed as somebody's lost 67 pounds
I'm sorry I'm tired of women saying
they're plus size and won't admit that
they have healthy habits unhealthy
habits Pierre right we love you Mel um
you speak facts but you got to let
others get the get a word in you're
overtaking the conversation Emily I was
raised to be a housewife that took care
of homes if I didn't have a job and a
career as if I didn't have a job and to
have a career as if I didn't have kids
or a family anyone else zero Fallout so
much uh yeast in these streets call them
Sarah Lee Dash them Munch I'm who is
more
who is more precious
who is more precious or more valuable
the painting which is priceless or the
painting that is worth one million life
University is watching action movies and
shaming violence hypocritical obviously
not one can be entertained by something
and not respected Lord games Pearl is so
fine King comp day hey MTR check your
DMs someone's trying to slide you gotta
check them
um a glass box hero respect is earned
not given dc-081
um soon AI will be able to scout the
internet to find everything a girl has
done and wants to hide and every man
she's ever slept with soon the game is
over black is Panther a marriage was
created to tame the average men corn
appears to be attempting to replace it
there will be greater social
consequences in the future
a scout and Bradley uh Pearl shout out
Maggie the substitute teacher is in the
chat she's really edgy yeah we love
Maggie
um mnj m j do everything I think many
women don't realize that the way they
move and carry themselves is the
ultimate snitch uh real bravado Network
big shout and support to MTR the big 50
super tie
we clapped the big ones um angel of
Sorrow exactly we don't want a girl
who's been passed around like a campfire
like a bag of crisps then expect a good
man to be satisfied with an old used up
bag with crumbles at the bottom uh the
Bikini Bottom Bandit
um she says she's plus-sized Lord games
I think stupidity comes with big
eyelashes who cares how much of how much
who cares how any of you feel personally
how the office sex work moral what's
wrong with these people
um km boss MTR looks like a dark-skinned
Andrew Tate uh zero Fallout Pearl is
Right some of these men need a release
Pearl is red some of these men need a
release or we might hold on Auntie some
of these men meet a release or we might
see an outburst in society there's only
a patch though unless there's an
incentive for regular regular men to get
married is fixed the West will fall like
Rome black is Panther before we ask
whether modern women deserve respect we
must first Define what is a woman
black has been their exploitation of a
woman's most precious resource is
disguised as empowerment as usual few of
the men that took the opportunity when
and all women lose a scout and Bradley
my ex-girlfriend was a stripper she
always came home wanting me Ronaldo some
I work a 10-hour day hours a day 46
I work 10 hours a day 46 to 50 hours a
week put in years of work as a
foundation
some men so I can pay enough bills and a
mortgage you think I will get enough
respect from the UPS upset gender
um
thank you Marcin for the Super Chat
Carlos Auntie with the truth bombs as
usual I love it Matt butcher a good
attitude is free and your best asset
ladies props to Pearl for her Super Chat
reading skills Auntie is killing it as
usual I never complimented on that so
thank you
a scout in Bradley men always have liked
nature natural for a wife um the rest is
a night growth potential um wish I wish
women realized realized a fat butt is an
insecurity uh Matt if as a man I provide
house food money Safety and Security
what is wrong with expecting return
Beyond sex black is Panther just because
we want to smash a freakish creature to
or satisfy a fetish it does not mean we
want to be seen in public and at public
functions with them we want wives not
plastic dolls shout out to Mark Henry on
the panel I'm a big fan uh black is pant
there
the reason we're having this discussion
is because men are treating women like
they would treat other men women
demanded equality now they're crying
about disrespect they don't want they
don't want respect they want special
treatment black is Panther
if a man is worshiping the ground woman
is walking on he is considered
disrespectful
um black is Panther
common courtesy common courtesy is given
respect is earned Carlos why all women
are prizes oh actually that's from a
previous show Let me refresh really
quick to see if there's any super chats
that came in while I was reading them
um
okay
um another 50 Super Chat
faucet media Melanie dropped the mic
pivotal moment we're going to hear about
this one for a while going viral
Cheyenne Healy it's nice to see someone
from Ireland on the panel it's a shame
there aren't more like her over here
um Tomo J note to girls the chat doesn't
hate you we're trying to bring back
positive
um naturally we all go through the red
pill rage good show Mr Pollock the more
bodies a woman has the less likely
she'll be able to pair bond um Carlos
why all women are prizes some women are
have gold medals where you first some
believe there are participation trophies
okay
do you guys think that
men are respected in society
why women no
no by other man yeah but by women no
I think they are they are yeah
I think um
I think that they are respected due to
the the position that they hold and the
amount of things that they do for the
society as a whole I think they are
perspected do you think most women are
aware how much men do for society as a
whole no
so then how are we they respect it if
women don't generally know that and they
make up the majority of society so 55
I'd say that a lot of women do respect
men I think speaking to your mic sorry I
think say most women don't respect men
is a
a bit of a high number to say but I
think a majority of women that want a
man do respect a man
there's a lot of women that say for
example for example like
where we have you like feminists they
don't think that men some of them don't
think men deserve there was as much
respect as do you think most women let
their do you think what most women in
relationships let their husbands lead
I think they should and I'm asking what
they do
um
like they respect him enough to trust
his authority well if you're in a
relationship then yeah you should
respect it I'm not asking sure I'm
asking what is
I think yeah most people in your life
you would say the woman you've never
heard anything like she wears the pants
in the relationship no no no no no no
okay okay go ahead
I'm sorry do you think men are respected
in society no
I don't I just I'm not in general
respects yes
um and obviously they should be but no
I've going back to the point I made
earlier about women
um listening to other women about what
it what we think men want if we listen
to men if we respected them this
wouldn't be an issue we would listen to
them we wouldn't be going to other women
and appeasing and competing with them
because we would know that's not even
what men want so if you respect them it
comes to honoring them listening to them
and Society does not reflect a general
overall population that respects men
because we aren't giving men what they
want men are complaining men are
desperate for women who respect them and
hear them and see them and we aren't
doing that so overall we don't respect
men
um I think majority of men are respected
in society
um even at situations in the gym you
might go to the gym and you're using
something and a man might come over
because you're a woman he kind of thinks
you can push you away or take your
weights or whatever what's he wouldn't
do that with a man maybe in certain
situations a woman with respect a man is
that common that's happened to me yeah
but I mean that's just in the gym but
just in general anyway like unless A man
gives you a reason not to respect him
then I think majority of the time you
would respect him so why do you think we
men are trash as a common saying no
matter the problem I know the issue if
most women respect men why do we have
those sayings I think there's just kind
of extremists that have gone through
situations where they have maybe gone
through a lot of times due to their own
fault because they're not learning but
and then they just take their anger out
on line making these expressions and
yeah just going forward with that do you
just think it's a minority I mean I
don't have that view on men because I
think if someone's trashed then they're
trash that's just a personal thing and
there are quite a lot of people that say
that but that's kind of what's put out
to you you don't really see the nice
stuff nice stuff sometimes do you think
most women respect the average Tesco
worker the average KFC where I don't
know what you guys have here the chicken
the the chicken shop worker it's one
thing to average or it's one thing to
respect successful men and men in you
know high power positions but do you
think most women respect average men
um I think most decent women do just as
respecting a person though I um I have
an interesting story about that because
just the other day being in London not
being from here I um I always engage I'm
always friendly just talking to
different people and I had an
interesting conversation with my Uber
driver the other day and he was telling
me about how he he has a nice car he has
his own business and things like that
but he doesn't drive his nice car when
he's doing Uber right why would we put
run up the mouse on a nice car right and
he has had his eye on a particular girl
here in London and he he was telling me
that that's generally the culture here
when he goes out and he's in his plane
clothes and he's in his Uber Prius
driving around girls aren't trying to
give him play but because they had
mutual friends he ended up going out
with her one night when he was he had on
his Louis Vuitton bag and he had on he
had his nice car the same girl who was
ignoring him was giving him attention in
the time of day now and he literally
told her
you know you ignored me the other day
right and she tried to downplay it and
laugh it off like oh haha no not at all
and from the males that I have
encountered here
um I would say it's the same in the in
the US too as well from a lot of girls
you see them and he's looking bummy and
he because he Works Sanitation or
whatever the case may be and you're like
uh whatever
um and then when you see them in a
different setting now you want oh he has
something oh he's flashy now he's this I
would absolutely say that that is the
culture and I've heard it from men's
mouth that story just two days ago from
my Uber driver and I was like a pod I
was like are you serious he's like yeah
and I told her get away like
no like I have no interest in you now
you just ignored me you've been ignoring
me for months and now that we're out you
see my nice car you see my Rolex you see
that I have stuff you're interested now
uh what do you think do you think most
women respect most men I don't think
they do no there's a lot of women now
these days that just want to stand on
their own two feet because it's society
and that's just the way it is and I
think a lot of women won't build of a
man so if she sees him at his lowest a
woman doesn't want that
I think that's wrong personally but yeah
is that what you did you said you had
three kids yeah I was with my ex from
when I was 14 until I was 23. we just
didn't work out we still get along you
know we're amicable and that's it
unfortunately it just didn't work out
for us
why not
um
because of a lot of women out here are
trash and they froze himself because
they see a man doing his thing and he's
got nice things and he I think he was
just a weak man and he accepted that
there's a lot of things that I wouldn't
do in the bedroom that these women was
willing to do with him so I think that's
just yeah it is women who know that he
was in a relationship um a lot of women
yeah a lot of them did yeah do you think
that's something that could be worked
out like work past did you ever try to
um yeah we tried we tried for a long
time and when we had a few beautiful
children you know why wouldn't we but
unfortunately I just couldn't get over
that I became paranoid I became
obsessing over these women that he
cheated on me with so it just didn't
work and I didn't want that environment
around my kids
um do you think most women respect most
men
um I think respectful women will respect
men but
not all obviously I'm asking most uh
probably not now no no
okay I think it's to do with the age
I think that
women my age and older do
women younger than me
they don't and as for a young lady there
there's nothing no woman can do out
there to my men that I ain't gonna do
myself
I'm doing everything I don't care
whether I've got to try and do handset
I'm disabled I will try and do a
handstand because no woman ain't gonna
have sex with me with my man
there's nothing I'm going for that okay
I'm doing everything so when I hear
women say oh that woman was willing to
do things that I won't do for my man and
I'm thinking myself but
what is it that you wouldn't do for your
man do you think that goes to the lack
of submission with this generation I was
thinking the same thing but is that like
a submission thing where your man is
wanting something Desiring especially if
he's willing to communicate it and he's
not embarrassed by it I would be of the
nature that I'm I'm attracted to you I
might not be the best but if you teach
me a little something we might get there
and if he wants it don't even once it
doesn't involve a third party yeah what
if he did ask that then what if I'm
announced it pardon what if he asked me
to do something I'm gonna do it that's
right I want to do I mean if he asks for
a third party is that where you draw the
line because you would know that in the
beginning because I'm not the only woman
he needs I can do everything okay I'll
even try I'll even try and double up
again I'm two people
but no no no no no no that's what I said
okay there's a limit he knows the limit
and he's pushed the limit
but no but I think that the younger
people the younger women they don't
respect they don't respect men and I
think it's the old bitter women
that don't I mean me I can say like I've
never heard of any of this before
because most of my friends are older
than me like 10 15 years older than me
and they're like married people
but I know they've got some bitter old
women out there that will tell
youngsters I mean I've even hadn't tried
me but because I know that I've got
older women out there that got sense and
I think that
no I think that young people I think
that's where it's at that's where it's
gone wrong with the young people because
the old people won't tell them
and you get people my age are still
going out they're trying to be young and
they're old it's not happening it might
depend on what kind of men you've had in
your life influence and growing up
growing up like I've got an amazing dad
and I've got amazing men in my family so
the respect for men is rooted there but
maybe if you have a either an absent
father or just I think that's a cop out
after all adults but all adults we know
right from wrong and we decide what to
do because you can have people their
parents are murderers and everything
like that they can go out to be decent
human beings I think I think it plays
into the lack of healing that this
generation won't adapt to and admit
right so even if your dad wasn't there
even if you didn't have a male figure
even if you've gone through traumatic
dating experiences who does the
responsibility lie in for you to take
accountability and say okay I don't want
to be bitter and lash out against random
men who I don't even know who I've never
even encountered and when we're gonna
say I want to be a better person I want
to be a decent person to identify where
this is coming from and do something
different if women are that unfunctional
they shouldn't be working they'll be out
there on the streets like tramps because
they're making all these excuses if
you've got the brain enough to go and do
a job you've got braided enough to sort
your life out there should be no excuse
because you're not stupid for the stupid
women go ahead
but
I'm tired of hearing I did have this I
didn't have that
trauma healing get along you know what
but no it's a part of it though you just
you said it earlier right when you
talked about what what it took for you
to become the woman it took work and
women these days aren't trying to do the
work I had a conversation earlier and I
personally as I once I realized Lauren
had daddy issues Lauren went to the
table and Lauren dealt with daddy issues
and then I began to recognize that
issues another woman and I would talk to
them and they would self-identify daddy
issues and I was shocked I was like wait
you know you have daddy issues because
if I had known earlier I would have
fixed some earlier I didn't know I had
that issues so until I fixed them but
there are women walking around knowing
that they are traumatized knowing that
they have gaps in them and they don't
want to address it because they don't
want to do the work it is hard work to
look inside of you and know that you
can't victimize yourself know that you
have to be accountable and to stand up
and say yeah my daddy did this he wasn't
present he wasn't whatever but that's
not on him I gotta forgive him and I
have to realize what that's done for me
and if I want a healthy relationship the
role the active role that I have to play
in evolving and becoming a better person
to get that and people don't want to
look in the mirror people do not want to
deal with themselves
can they do it for their bosses so
that's a lot of rubbish because women do
it for the if your boss said if you're
in the job and your boss said well I
want you to train and do this then we'll
go for it if your man says you're doing
this then we ain't going to want to do
it I mean I just think we don't live in
we just get away with it because we
don't face consequences for anything
it's like there's so many Sims that'll
put up with disrespectful behavior and
still date them and still marry them
still give them children when they don't
respect them I mean how many times we
hear happy wife happy life how many
times do we hear she wears the pants in
the relationship is that a relationship
any woman really wants to be in where
she's exactly they end up divorcing them
and then we're in the same cycle when a
guy wants to make a decision like she'll
call him toxic and controlling I mean I
hear all the time on the show if he asks
you to take down your social media he's
toxic and controlling when that's
actually quite reasonable to not want
random men looking at your girl on the
Internet it's actually what you're
posting as well like if you're out here
what am I on your post and all these
like it depends what type of things that
you're posting I would feel if you're
just posting picture every once a year
and like that picture's with your man or
with your family or with your friends
and you're not like being excessive
enough I won't find fair enough well if
you're out there posts and like your
tits you're a buoy your body everything
and you're in a relationship you need to
see that you're actually the problem in
that relationship because you're getting
the views from men you know what I mean
and you're putting yourself in that
light and men are going to like that
damn pictures but especially but the
whole point of submission is you don't
ask him why yeah we had a girl Maggie on
the show and they said he asked you to
take down your social media and she has
the most mild cooking stuff she just
said it wouldn't even be a conversation
and so it's like but it's so unheard of
from women to just listen to men not you
know it's not every man like don't
listen to the homeless man on the street
but you know what I'm saying
um MTR what do you think yeah um I mean
to just sum it up no like respect uh for
men is at a
um All Time Low
um
I think that respect for men within our
society today is more so tied to what
that man can provide in the utility
within that like short story so um
before I started on YouTube
um I consider myself a hobbyist
um and so one of the things that I did
prior to turning the video camera on
myself is to become a photographer now
at the same time you know I was you know
post MBA working a six-figure job and a
fortune whatever company but I wanted to
do photography so I eventually started
to like book gigs
um within that one of the gigs that I
booked
um I it was at like a wedding party or
something like that
um and
and then I'm having a conversation with
a young woman at the wedding party I saw
her kind of looking I saw it kind of
choose and decided to welcome and have a
conversation with him and like the
low-level barometer of disrespect
uh just based off of oh so you like is
this what you do like this little
photography thing and I was like oh you
dirty dirty wench that's what I was
thinking I don't want to say it like
that just because like you know I was
gonna I was gonna get paid for the day
you know I don't want to cause a a
brouhaha within the establishment right
so you know just based off of being what
they consider to be an average earner or
an average worker a lot of that respect
is derived from there but you know
that's why I like on my channel I tell
so many of the men to continue to work
on you know yourselves and utility
within your life because people no one
owes you favors no one will care right
like men and women are judged within our
society off of different metrics right
but as a man you should know what the
metrics are judged off of and if you
choose to play well this is the cost of
that it is right as opposed to men that
go their own way so no there's not a um
a whole level of respect you know where
I also see it as well I see it outside
of the club when I see the young women
putting fingers in men's faces
where they're instigating fights because
of something that might have happened
inside of the club if you had a respect
for a man that you'd understand that a
man is more than likely stronger than
you and he could do damage to you equal
rights equal love he can do damage too
clearly if he decided that he didn't
want to play with your [__] no more
but no this is not a level of respect
because if he respected a man that you
don't understand then you would respect
his hand strength his arm strength that
he's much bigger than you that's just
being smart
disrespectful people do dumb [__] why do
you think people automatically think
that the woman's the victim when she
gets hit and when often times she hit
first women are looked at as fragile
little beings and oh you can't hit a
woman it's that woman out there saying
she wants to meet girls and they playing
it to that victim and it's not even it's
not even necessarily that you put your
hand on a guy women don't understand the
power of our influence and our voice
right it's how you talk to a man right
if you can stir up some things in him
and entice him in a way that make him
want to put his hand on you and people
will say oh it wasn't justifiable
because she didn't hit you even though
that's not appropriate either but it's
it's like women why are you running your
mouth like this to a man I mean what's
what's worse verbal abuse or physical
abuse I think I'm gonna say I'm gonna
say verbal for a man absolutely who do
you think verbally abuses the other
gender more about no women 100.
we also got to thank our media as well
like shout out to Oprah The Color Purple
um what she's done to the image of the
black man in society today uh and she's
completely right like everyone is just
walking around thinking that you know
men are just uh especially black men too
we're Destroyers I didn't actually I
didn't actually watch a lot of Oprah
growing up so like what what did she do
so specifically have no idea so so
specific to image uh image being
um formed within our media today
um I know we did the king Rich's podcast
not too long ago and we talked about
blackmail image and how um it's kind of
formed today and what it is and what
they said like what is the what is the
image of man uh black man you know
within America today and the first word
that came out was Thug
um I think someone other words was like
a beater or things like that right so
you know there's been images within
media that has promoted that we are a
big bad tough strong and that you know
women can do no wrong women must be
protected outside of their behavior you
know I I think you know back to that
respect question that there's a certain
behavior of women that deserves more
respect
right like of the women right like that
one-on-one that comes out is Maggie The
Substitute Teacher who's gracious with
his presence this past week you sit and
you talk to Maggie for like a little bit
Maggie was up in the kitchen for 12 damn
hours and I'm not saying that you gotta
be up in the kitchen but she she came in
to a place that she was unfamiliar with
and graced it with feminine ease and
presence her influence So within
feminine ease and presence guess what as
a man I am biologically driven to
protect that
biologically and she likes it she just
it's religious it comes off of her just
afterwards I went up to her and I was
just like oh my goodness I love this I
want I want to be a part of this what
programs do you have like I can sign up
for because it's just it's amazing it
literally changes the the whole
atmosphere when she talks it's a respect
everyone gets quiet you want to listen
to her you want to honor that and that's
that's what we need to push for women in
society because we need if we return to
that the power that is in that men would
naturally protect us and here's the
thing it's one thing to to say it but
um his act because I was like to think
about about this earlier like how do I
because I I can say to you like listen
this based off of her presence it's just
like if something was to happen I'd be
like man you good
based off the aura in the room or
whatever that changed right so it's just
like how do we get more women in the
understanding of like that's what
femininity is that ease is I think it's
so rare because it's a failure on the
mother's part
I mean even from two parent households
you absolutely see a lack of femininity
in the in the mothers like how many how
many moms genuinely that you know if if
the husband made a decision a big
decision for the household that she did
not agree with she would just say okay
yes sir
that's pushing it sir
I don't I don't for me personally I'll
speak to that writing my mom is amazing
super sweet loving but there is a level
of passive aggressiveness that I inherit
from it because even though she might
not go tick for tack for him she might
not go but there she'll have an attitude
for a few days and it's justifiable for
her attitude and the silent treatment
and things like that and I was like I
never want to treat my husband that way
right and so over that was in my younger
days but as we've evolved and she's
matured she's come out of that a little
bit more and it's it's not a thing but
inadvertently when I was growing up I
was exposed to that right and even um my
mom was she worked and so a lot of um
the things that I had to learn I was in
an environment with men right I had a
stepfather two two older stepbrothers
and a younger brother and that's the
environment that I was in with a mom who
worked do you feel like your mom failed
to teach you femininity absolutely and
we've I've had that conversation with
her absolutely was it do you feel like
it would have been better if she was at
home with you
not rather than working not necessarily
and I'm gonna tell you why because my
mom and her side of the family they come
from a place of very private very keep
even if she was home she wouldn't have
taught me because if for them it was a
sense of Pride and it's something we
don't talk about why didn't why didn't
she learn femininity from like her mom
but I think she did oh she did but she
did in that generation how they learned
it and so it's not that she didn't teach
me anything absolutely she taught me
stuff but the things that I had to just
kind of through osmosis not really but
in college when I got around my friends
and when I when I observed them they
were they took my level of feminine
energy and hygiene to another level
because I had good friends in a circle
but the responsibility shouldn't have
lied on them and it didn't and then I
got to a certain age and it's like well
I want to get even better about this but
these are honestly they're hard
conversations to have when you have you
don't feel a level of vulnerability and
comfort that for whatever reason I don't
believe my mom felt who um I'm curious
who on the panel feels like their mom
taught them to be a proper wife
Auntie Jenny
yeah really wow
this is crazy I was raised by my great
grandmother but I felt like she taught
me the proper way and just unfortunately
didn't work for me and guys this is just
a random group of women this isn't like
cherry-picked this is you guys had
recruiters reach out to you it's copy
and paste Instagram people with open
profiles
um usually and I will say my grandmother
my grandmother influences Unfortunately
they died when I was young but they it
wasn't influence from them but if it's
not cultivated throughout life if it's
only for a certain stint it's the
seedest planet but we need somebody else
to come along and cultivate that and to
grow that so it's in there but I had to
go in later in life when I realized it
wasn't cultivated properly go back and
re-stimulate that and cultivated yeah
and I'm not saying you can't learn it
later but it's just like you're starting
it's like you're competing with women
that were raised to be wives so they've
been learning to be a wife from 10 years
old and you you said you started at like
27 28 so having to relearn right so even
even if you learned you know for
five years it's like I'm compared
it's an honest question when I'm dating
now and people are like well you're 33
you're single you're accomplished
whatever whatever you're beautiful why
aren't you married it is a very good
question do you feel that you've become
the man you wanted to marry so man so uh
maybe no no so so I'm saying like in
terms of your accomplishments like you'd
want a guy with your similar
accomplishments like you're in shape
you'd want a guy in shape like you like
would you say a lot of your
accomplishments like have maybe become
the man you wanted to marry
I wouldn't because I don't necessarily
want to marry a man who's established in
that way I'll marry somebody who's just
literally a driver right that isn't you
wouldn't prefer it you wouldn't prefer
someone and I'm I'm gonna be really
honest right now and say not necessarily
because what I find is those type of men
the character isn't always there right
because they are looking for the 20 year
olds who are being equal so everything
being equal driver lawyer
you wouldn't pick the lawyer I don't
want to yeah I would never marry another
lawyer the debates in the conversation
I I find it so interesting that um women
are not demonized for raising women but
men are demonized for not raising men
it's it's so it's so interesting to me
and it just goes back to you know the
privilege of being a woman and that
we're I'm judged by different standards
that's so true because whenever there's
a [__] kid or they'll always say oh he
had a deadbeat dad but they never really
talk about the women I mean that in a
way had dead Beats beat moms because
they weren't presents it has to be
extreme like she has to be strung out
and yeah I'm sorry I didn't want to
interrupt but
[Music]
I wasn't raised to be a housewife or to
be a wife at all anything in that was
your mom in the picture yeah so my mom
and dad are still we each other
dude was it was did she work or like my
mom and dad they both worked so like my
nanny and Granddad would look after me
when I was younger but I would still see
how my mom would treat my dad and what
she would do for my dad you know I still
took that into account of how I treat
him on that I'm just curious how did you
like growing up with a nanny did you so
it was my own it was my grandmother it
was my own grandmother sorry for me
so you know I was still getting the same
time you know what I mean so I can only
like I said I can only speak for myself
in this I wasn't taught right you do
this for a man or you do that for a
month but I see in what was done for a
man and I took that into account okay so
this is how I'll treat my husband I'll
cook for my husband if he wanted to put
something into the house he'd want
something to the house if he's if he's
the main Breadwinner if not if he's
demanded house you know did you did you
grow up like fixing your data plate ever
did they ever teach you that sort of
stuff and kind of I got taught like if
you're making dinner for yourself you're
making dinner for everybody no matter
who is around you you know what I mean
that's what I was kind of so where did
you feel like you were lacking
like what what do you feel like wasn't
there
I feel like I wasn't taught properly how
you notice hole when you're younger men
will like pick on you and like oh if
he's picking on you it means he likes
you this is I see that as now as well I
wasn't taught that like when you're
older men still might not be like you
you're amazed and you're a princess like
the Disney World so do you feel like you
were more allowed to by the media or by
your family probably by the media rather
than my family yeah in my opinion
definitely and they they sold you a
dream sort of oh one million do you guys
do you guys who of you feels like you
were
sold trying to write away the phrases
question who
who feels like
they were sold at Prince Charming that
was never going to come like there was
some perfect guy and it's okay if you
don't I'm just wondering you do I'm
still waiting for him I think it was a
harsh reality because my mum and dad
have been together like just I'm just
curious just one no me this one no you
didn't feel like that you didn't feel
like okay cool go ahead so my mom and
dad have been together like from like
really young they've been together ever
since they're not married but they've
been together like a long time so I
always just thought that's what happens
like so when I met my first boyfriend it
didn't work out it was like oh okay like
I am a relationship person I love love
like I just wanted it to be like that so
whenever I met someone and it failed it
was always like a oh you know so it
wasn't that I don't think anyone failed
me but
it was like a full sense of like oh like
you know what I mean you do say are you
in a relationship now no no okay
um and you say you're you're a
relationship person do you feel like you
present yourself like one
um
I wouldn't say I'm really looking for
that now probably that's why it maybe
comes across like that no I'm asking you
I didn't say you did or you didn't
um I'm not really looking so I wouldn't
say I present myself as someone that's
looking like do you do you want to look
in the future maybe I don't know I just
think when when you have so many I think
so many failed you know like you said
like you're you're numbers go up and you
know like you I just don't I want I
don't want to keep
um hitting a brick wall like I'm just
like oh I'd rather just focus on being
happy focus on making money and yeah
have you ever thought about why you
failed in the in the past you know why
um
I think I
not to be deep but I think I'd go for
like broken men and I try to fix them
and I've just always done it do you
think you are what you attract
um
I don't think I don't think so maybe I
don't know I wouldn't say so no I just
I'm quite an imp empath so I just like
to I like to care
yeah yeah and just be nice to just not
fix someone it'd be nice to meet someone
and them just be like you know just good
have you have you met guys that you
don't have to fix
um not in a relationship time probably
no never like not on the street not you
know
I mean like I said unless I don't know
I've just been in relationships to be
honest and then when I'm in a
relationship I'm not actively you know
so and then if I'm not in a relationship
I'm dealing with
what happened and then yeah so I don't I
don't really if unless I'm interacting
on like a friendship level
I'm chair to your side you thought you
were about to say something no no I was
just uh intently listening you know I
but I will quickly comment that um
I've been waiting my turn inside you
know what I'm saying but I thought that
was a very interesting uh line of
questioning right because what Pro asks
is is that you know do you attract what
you are and what you only find to see is
to be broken right so you know I think
like you know we are the relationships
that we get into we're all reflections
of us
so you know my next question is is you
know have you done work within yourself
in therapy to understand kind of where
your deficiencies might be so you can
subtract better the way that I'm talking
about broken would be things that I
don't necessarily have come from to like
a broken home may be as affected a
person I don't come from that
um maybe substance abuse again I've not
had that around me so in in the
instances that I'm talking about and I
wouldn't say it does really reflect on
me maybe in other aspects that I've not
dived into but I don't think necessarily
know if the man of your dreams came
around right now do you think you would
be prepared for him I don't know I think
I have healing to do to be honest
you need to heal something that's broken
so you consider yourself broken
huh maybe maybe I've done a broken feels
quite harsh I know I use it to describe
them but on me I'm not ready
on a harsh intent it's just something
that I've I've stumbled on like I've
realized I didn't know at first because
people mask it and then the deeper
you're you're with someone you're like
oh
it's like if you're afraid to get in a
relationship now then wouldn't you say
something's broken
because you're hurt right yeah yeah yeah
because we're better together than we
are apart would you agree or disagree
if you're with the right person yeah you
don't gotta be a caveat on that you know
we're tribal people
really together is better than a part
that's the way that we're designed to be
the amount of mental health issues that
have sprung up since
the 19 started because now we are an
at-home culture and it's getting a lot
better right now up in front of our TV
screens whether it be social media or
what have you
um the rate of prescriptions depression
of medications are skyrocketing and
going through the roof and I think it a
lot of it has to do with the lack of
community in person in reality community
and relationships that we are building
the most important relationship that
you're going to build throughout your
life is going to be with a significant
other so if you were to find the Menace
broken but you're unwilling to Define
yourself as broken which already right
there that's there's an issue within
that as well yeah right I think we all
got to have a degree of reality within
ourselves right me you know I'm I wanted
a flat though but I feel like my some of
my Brokenness is from how I've been
treated rather than maybe like I think I
was just happy like I'm very like um
naive like I'm just I love you know I
just want to love non-broken wouldn't
allow themselves to be mistreated
true true so it all falls back on you
yeah true no one else but you
can I can I say I I just want to say
something in um from a loving place and
this is just not just for you this is
just for still being in the healing
journey and process as of myself but
when you spoke about the Brokenness in
men and just in general when we identify
with people it's a cause and it's an
effect to things you spoke to the effect
of it right oh they are um strung out
um they're homeless whatever the effect
of something may be that's just the
effect we have to go back to the root
cause of where that came from looking at
the the process and the different things
that happen to them and I think when we
do that we might find that we align with
them in more of a way that identifies
our own Brokenness and our own hurt and
shows that we both have similar healing
to do
um in that process and that's just the
way I think about people I always ask
myself why why did you do this why where
is this coming from in your life and it
started with me I had to say okay you
got Daddy Issues girl but where did this
come from and where have I seen this
cycle reappearing in my life and let's
go back to each and every one of them
and reframe it and fix it and reframe it
until my thinking at a default is reset
and redone and that's the part of the
healing process and it still has to
happen over and over again because the
brain is so powerful our negative
thoughts they happen so quickly it we
have to in order to rewire a negative
thought we have to think something
positive a minimum of seven times and a
negative thought just takes that because
the impact of a negative thought the
emotional feeling of it is so powerful
that it takes us rewiring that with
positive thinking and shutting down the
set the negative thought over and over
again and then once you do that you have
to continue to do that and that's hard
because we are our own worst critics and
so when you are going through that
healing process it is work and it takes
time but you have to identify what the
root trigger is what is the root factor
of this that has caused me to go down
this the effect that I'm having the
Brokenness I get you I'm a lover I love
love and sometimes we can say that we
crave it and we want it so bad but if we
are compromising that and we are not
ending up with the relationships that we
want at some point you have to look and
identify itself I'm a good person I love
heart but what is broken inside of me
that I'm not getting that that I'm not
attracting that um go ahead I just
wanted to say that it seems like most
women
most single modern women with businesses
they concentrate more on the business
improving their business and improving
themselves because it sounds like all
the modern women out there with
businesses need therapy
they need some kind of help but rather
than concentrating them themselves
they're concentrating on the business
and then they want to look for a man
they might not give a [__] about your
business you know I mean so the energy
that you're putting into your business
put into yourself and then perhaps
you'll get a man and he might support
you having a business but right now all
I can hear is single women having
business they need therapy they're
concentrating their business is
successful
but their brains [__] up mm-hmm
yeah they need to concentrate forget
about your business because the men care
more about you having a good mental
health than having a good business so
forget about your business and
concentrate on your own mental health
you know what's crazy about that sorry
go ahead yeah I was gonna say would you
just say this so it's so important and
honestly you know big upset of content
in the sector and I you know as because
it's not very humble to Big up yourself
but like a lot of modern women today
hate the content in the sector but this
content in the sector is what's going to
help them to understand how [__] up
their situations currently are it
creates the burning platform for them to
want more and do more just even you
and understanding that there might be a
degree of Brokenness within that you
wouldn't even quite come to that
conclusion unless you were sitting in
this particular platform right here to
understand the burning platform and
here's the thing once you begin to heal
that Brokenness you begin to understand
other thoughts feelings ideologies or
things that you believe then will begin
to change we had a whole conversation
about the sex work thing before I bet
you if you become into an unbroken State
one where you say that God that I'm
looking at right now I'm in a good
position to attract that guy once you
get there those feelings will change but
in a broken State what's all around the
Brokenness is ideas that you have that
have nothing to do with the togetherness
mindset try try you know I would say
when they say manifesting manifestation
try manufacturing actions yeah everybody
sits there and they want to Manifest
this idea man but nobody puts in the
hard work boom Oh I have oh my gosh I
have something so fun to share with the
panel oh okay I don't think so it's an
evil smile man he's already seen this
um
[Laughter]
MTR if you have any words that we should
add to this list Auntie I'm open to
feedback same with the ladies let me
know if you think any of these words are
unfair to have on this list let me know
if I'm just chatting [__] you know I've
got the British
yes yes okay okay so I'm gonna say words
that us as women should get rid of oh in
our vocabulary okay so this is uh
okay partner horoscope signs I'm looking
for a connection energy trauma toxic
masculinity my truth healing
narcissistic ex-boyfriend abusive
ex-boyfriend great accusation with no
evidence don't judge yeah but
manifesting equals I want to do no work
and get the outcome as a woman I did too
much and I let him walk all over me
equals I like cheaters and toxic men and
I will choose them and be toxic as well
and not admit that I had any part to
play except hashtag giving too much
generational trauma I make the same
mistakes in my parents made and I'm too
dumb to learn from their mistakes and
instead I will blame the same mistake
and I will make the same mistake and
blame it on them in my feminine energy
men always stare and approach me I will
be submissive for the right man men are
trash equals I take no accountability
for the negative part that myself or any
woman play in relationships he needs to
make six figures equals I have no
emphasis on character I don't need a man
but I want a man my ring needs to cost
this much Financial abuse I became
feminine I need a man to maintain you we
need to Vibe I feel like I'm traditional
um when I have done no work to become
traditional Manish I will be submissive
for the right man who hurt you
internalize misogyny I am leveling up
together I need a man to be on my level
level Boss B I'm a bad [__] these men
are broken Dustin
he needs to add he needs to add to what
I have going on in my life not all women
equals that is a problem with women but
I won't admit it's a problem
um I need someone to match my energy I
am his peace
I read it better than I read the super
chats because I've spent a lot of time
writing that sometimes you wrote it and
because of the letters people spell
things wrong in the Super Chat okay
because they don't you only get so many
characters so you're kind of making out
what they say anyways you should have a
copy for that you know like start the
clock somebody yeah yeah anyway so what
what did I get wrong I didn't hear
astrological signs it now she said that
um
[Music]
okay yeah go ahead add the one we have
to add is broken man because women are
broken too but it's more pain I'm sorry
man this is calling you out
women are also broken but see it like I
said I took this panel to show you that
you actually were broken and I just want
to say women say men are F boys but how
do you know he's a f boy if you didn't
let him F yes so does that make you a f
girl does it make you easy does it make
you for the street you don't want a man
to say you for the street but you can
call him a f boy I don't deal with f
boys so like women who who protect their
box they're not dealing with that energy
but if you've been effed and ran through
you have to say to yourself I've allowed
this man to be a f boy to my most
precious my most precious possession on
The Dating Market which is my womb my
body and it we say you know my body my
choice and don't objectify me but a lot
of times we objectify ourselves the way
we dress the way we present and then we
we blame a man but like I never heard
the term F boy until I start getting on
Tick Tock and I dealt in these spaces
and I'm like well why did you let him
hunch on you
they need to say that no
[Music]
[Laughter]
he hit me harder than I hit him oh damn
it's still a hit what about body
positivity like is that sort of mainly
for a specific body or is that it's only
for women it's only for women where
where have you seen a 300 pound man on
the front of Cosmo or any other magazine
it's only for women and and you will see
the same women who will put down men or
shame them for their height but where's
your body positivity for a man who's
five feet tall but you want a man to
accept you as you are accept him as he
is but see it's it's not equal
broke man positivity yes ma'am
listen listen I want to talk about this
as well and I know like you know the
guys actually the other one of the guy
here but you know from from my
perspective
um
like you know as a as a young boy right
like and you're watching these shows on
TV where they're talking about a man uh
a man's member the size matter like how
dare you how how how the nerve of you
cowards to get up on TV and to talk
about on daytime talk show TV and to
talk about the size matter does your
viscous in this matter yeah because
because
y'all are just as different with your
insides as we are different with our
outsides so y'all could judge all this
ever in terms of size depth
circumference where it's actually
positioned
small dick energy
from a genetic perspective as well but
like the the actual oil on the inside of
it like it's it's a lot different as
well so like if it doesn't go right it
doesn't all have to do with his member
you know but to talk about that it
happens young boys listening to that
sometimes maybe because it's damaging
maybe that's what it is because the
women always say that the man's dick is
too small but the women ever say my
fannies do be
foreign
they will claim the same body positivity
I can be 500 pounds and accept me as I
am but the same woman will claim small D
energy with something that's genetic
where if you controlled how much you ate
and you exercise and discipline yourself
you can actually control doesn't mean to
be a supermodel in a size you know I
don't know in the UK with the sizes are
but like size two and zero like super
skinny but a lot of men aren't even
looking for that but you will claim body
positivity but the same woman will say
you got small D energy I'm not even
talking about that I'm talking about a
woman a woman would always say oh he
didn't satisfy me because dick small but
you never had a man say a funny was too
big I was rolling around in it
was so much air rushing around yeah you
know yeah
I have a really great um addition to
this list thank you thank you to Bose
nuts um
my ex was a narcissist yeah you just
fell for that yeah
okay this is what I've come to conclude
I've come to conclude this okay wait
wait wait I need I need to get this off
my chest okay I have come to conclude
that either 50 of all men are
narcissists or women are all dating the
same narcissists or maybe women are the
problem no just so scientifically has
been shown uh this is the research so
let's get into data and not just these
rooms okay girl you gotta add I'm a
queen
why
[Laughter]
okay what's the data um disagree about
something right now like everyone sort
of agreeing with a lot of things make
your mind and I feel like I need to
disagree about some a few things
actually a few things on that list
actually I'd personally remove I don't
know exactly what but one stood out to
me now I've had a few exes
a lot of the exes I've had I've been
very very nice men
I I'd say recently I'd say about in
October I got out of a relationship and
I was with this guy for a year
and this guy was genuinely abusive does
that mean I cannot use the term like I
had an abusive ex does that mean that I
like should diminish my sort of feelings
because of that because genuinely I had
to go through like victim support and
things like that I had to put things in
place for my safety so as a woman do you
think that I should not use that because
I know you are laughing and joking and
whatnot about like narcissism obviously
I know there's only a small percentage
of men that are actually narcissistic
and I think people that ruin it is the
women that fold these words out like for
example women that lie about getting
raped or women that lie about getting
like sexually assaulted they ruin it
they say sorry I say they ruin it for
the actual women that have been victim
and I know again I'm one of those people
that believe in accountability I
genuinely believe that you should take
accountability for the things that have
happened to you and you should fix
yourself but I just don't think it's
fair to say that you have you should
diminish your own experience because
other women want to throw out the words
or the phrases and thank you again it
sort of brings it down to yourself
um thank you it sort of just brings it
down to the fact that it makes you feel
a bit worse about it sort of thing
because again I've been through things
and again I can say maybe I've not been
the perfect person maybe some of the
things I've done are my fault but that
does not diminish my experience of the
things that I have had happened to me
okay can I just say yeah no from a woman
that's I'm going to speak a normal
that's been abused right in my day you
call the police nothing happened in your
day you've got all the things out there
you've got victim support I never read
it so why are you staying in it I've got
no sympathy for people nowadays I went
for a [__] so you went you went for an
abusive relationship you know what I
don't give a [__] if a man was going
through a relationships
I can say the same things
all right you call the police if you
call the police what happens to you
because the police
as far as I'm concerned you're in an
abusive relationship the doorstep
nowadays they've got everything there
you can walk out but do you not
understand people can genuinely [__]
manipulate you as somebody that's not
grown up with the best [__]
you were young right as someone that's
not grown up you're the best Role Models
sorry it's hard for you to just click on
your own immediately what were your role
models
all I'm going to say is that you said
you were young I was young you said you
abused I was abused you they called the
police right because in my day I called
the police and nothing happened because
they were saying it was a domestic right
so we're here talking about stuff and
you're going to go against everything
I'm not going against somebody saying
that these things happen no no no okay
no pearls just brought up a list of
words like women what are you saying
that you cannot use them but that's the
word don't stick on them
get ways use and you've come up and
you're using the same thing again to
reiterate my point I clearly said to you
yeah I am a woman that believes in
taking accountability and the woman
that's healing I am a 21 year old girl
I'm not necessarily as matured as you
lot or I'm not necessarily as
experienced as you're not a girl you're
a grown woman if you've had sex in that
relationship don't use the word girl
because you will say and I don't mean
this to put you down listen my mother
was raped it for it's
at 14.
with um a weapon to her
her mother she was raised in section
eight I don't know if you have that over
here welfare yeah okay she had no father
at home she didn't meet her father until
she was pregnant with me at 30 at his
funeral when he was in the casket
everything you talk about people have
went through worse and it's not to
diminish what you've gone through
what you've gone through is a Learning
lesson for you to do better like my
mother then went on and did better than
her family through horrible
circumstances who took her in were nuns
Catholic nuns when her mother kicked her
out
from being assaulted at 14 and pregnant
that's how I have my oldest sister
so what I'm saying to you what you went
through use it as a learning lesson use
it to feel who you want to be in the
future
and realize the world has no sympathy
for any of us the only person who cares
about us the most is yourself
and you you use that as a learning
lesson to never let someone manipulate
you this is the issue that we have a lot
of times women will say I was a victim
of this and you were
okay it's not nobody doesn't believe you
or anything like that absolutely we know
the trauma and even their psychological
um I I would say things that can someone
can do to you that can break you down we
even talk about Stockholm syndrome and
all these these things are very real in
psychology
but what you have to say now is say out
of all that list she said you have to
say you know
how can I now
learn that lesson so that I no longer
can be a victim to such a monster I
don't say and and you have to say take
accountability and say how am I choosing
and do I have am I purposely choosing
women in my life to guide me am I coming
under discipline and Leadership have I
made changes are there were there people
in my life that said this is not a good
guy but I still chose to be with this
person or I saw the red flags and it's
not to point blame we all make mistakes
every single person in this room has not
lived a perfect life so it's not about
um
saying that you it was somehow your
fault you're very young
but now what happens is a lot of you
guys are very young but the world now
sees you you use the word girl and the
reason why I said you're a woman is that
now the world is going to hold you
accountable as a woman and you're going
to be a mother you're going to be
somebody's grandmother you're going to
be everything you've gone through is a
lesson and so what you want to do for
your life now is take what has happened
digest it and accountability looks like
this
why did I choose that what didn't my my
family of origin not give me after that
situation have I sought out the
counseling the help that I need am I
surrounding myself with people that you
know that I can learn from so that I can
do better what I find a lot of times is
a lot of times we'll be victimized and
we'll go through things and then we'll
wall out we'll go off because
emotionally we don't know how to deal
with the situation
and and I think what the point is is
nobody here wants you to be a victim
ever again we want you to have strength
and we want your daughters we want your
family we want you to have a husband we
want you to be taken care of we want you
to be loved on in a way that you may not
have experienced but in order to get
that you know what happens to a lot of
women who have been through that
situation you continue to attract that
same man so unless you pause on dating
pause or you're very young you don't
even need to date right now
and do the internal work reading books
how many books on relationships have you
read how many things have you have you
done to work on your healing through
therapy if you can't afford therapy I
think in the UK this stuff is free and
the U.S is a struggle bus but you know
because we have to pay for everything
but like have you explored every Avenue
because you say you know what I have to
care about me more than anyone else and
I can never allow another person so when
I happened to my mother what she did is
those nuns took her and she had no one
and I won't go into details of
um how horrific it was but imagine being
violated as that as a child and being
pregnant and then your own mother who
was for the streets had children by
different men competed against you for
different men did not believe you and
didn't want another mouth to feed and
kicked you out in that situation
my she just tried to find what she could
and those nuns helped her she got her
GED in the U.S that's like your high
school diploma and then she said she
didn't talk to her family for seven
years she said I'm gonna do better than
all of them she joined the military in
the U.S became ROTC she went to college
graduated I grew up in the Pentagon
under Colin Powell and people in the U.S
you guys may not know who these people
are but um I interned at the White House
and I she raised me in private school
she got married my father and had me and
it was a lot going on so I only want to
say this to you Pearl is not bringing
this up to re-victimize you because it's
very serious but don't take it as a
criticism yeah but if we don't say it to
you A lot of times you will still be
attracted to whatever energy and and I
believe in spirituality whatever Spirit
you were attracted to you will continue
to attract that unless you say you know
what what was in me that I saw red flags
in this man and I stayed why you know
and and how can I heal and grow from
this so I can do better and get better
nobody's putting you down we want you to
heal and I and I I want you to
understand that that we understand and
we absolutely do not blame you you're
very young but I can see you going far
if you can take the accountability and
heal and do and make better choices in
men because they don't deserve you a
demon like that who would abuse you does
not deserve you and we don't want you to
be attracted to that same Spirit again
I think you're right in saying that
because again I know I just went a bit
berserk about the words but I think
about it and saying what you do say
manifesting itself so like if I am
saying you saw words then again it can
happen again in something because I like
you said I'm attracting that sort of
energy but
yeah um I really appreciate what you
just said and I definitely do agree with
it I just think sometimes people can be
a bit harsh in the way that they sort of
say things sorry for being so
straightforward but man that's where I
am I'm not apologizing no no you're fine
um yeah currently at least though how
I'm going
about two months or I don't know is it a
male or female therapist female female
and I just tend not to really like I
speak about it but I just don't really
think it's helping can I tell you that
I'm the men in the space like MTR and
there's other men in the space this is
one thing Kevin Samuels was a good
friend of mine and a lot of women were
upset with him
um because he would speak harshly and
but one of the things that he understood
is a lot of women that had no leadership
and guidance and Direction ahead you
know they were lied to their entire
lives they've been victimized by men in
a very um harsh way he was very harsh
with men in fact she this just went
viral women or just discovering how he
went crazy on men like way harder than
women
and
um and I talked he one of the things he
said was that like no one's talking to
them people are just allowing our women
to be victimized and and and and and
telling them what they want to hear so
one of the things I would advise you to
do is to listen to men like MTR there's
a lot of men in the space
that if you actually listen to them
befriended men in that space they would
give you protection
and especially if you come with a humble
spirit and you're listening and you will
learn from them how men think and you
will start to see wait I've seen a man
like MTR who is talking about high
achieving and and this that and the
other and and what the expectations are
and you start to see when a guy comes
across you again who's like basic and
and you could start to see those red
flags because you're just like I've seen
other men who are not this way who are
you know who are who are different who
speak different you may not been exposed
to it so if a man comes with you with
the same red flag energy that could
victimize you you'll know better you
won't even be attracted to anymore
because you have that exposure and if
you befriend these men instead of making
a lot of women make them their enemy but
a lot of these men will will love you
and give you advice and and treat you
with respect and if you brought a man in
a direction and ask them advice they
would be happy to tell you the truth
truth about that man but this is the
thing a lot of women will hear the truth
we will notice those red flags from our
family and friends or we know in our
spirit but we're attracted to something
but we're not willing to step away we
there's a little bit of rebellion in US
If we're honest we want what we want I'm
grown I'm gonna make my own choice but
as you grow and as you get older these
are things are going to be important
because you're going to tell your
daughters or your children the same
thing or you may raise your sons to
never victimize a woman you got to know
what that looks like
um
I was going to say something but it's
just absolutely gone out my head um I
just feel like me personally I've been
disadvantaged a bit growing up because
I've never really felt like I have been
protected by a man
um again I'm not trying to you
a father I do but he's just very like
distant
um I've never really like had like did
he not grow up with you separate
um so he I lived with him in a split
family from probably about 10 years old
but he's he came from uh Sierra Leone
and he didn't he didn't speak very well
English you don't know much about like
the Western culture and whatnot he was
just very again emotionally distant he
was a bit strict but like he never
really taught me core values or like
what to see in a man he was a little bit
abusive as well which is I think one of
the reasons why I don't I wouldn't say I
seek abusive men but I don't originally
now I've started looking into it I spot
the signs but originally I did be around
either emotionally unavailable men or
men that are
abusive so I feel like I had a bit of
disadvantage at that point like you were
saying earlier like with the whole when
you grow up
um
be involved to be a housewife I'd never
really got that so I feel like I've been
disadvantaged in that sense but it's
something that I'm currently working on
and something that like obviously I'm
currently healing myself before I get
into another relationship because I
don't want to hurt myself again with a
man that I feel does not deserve me
um but again I just feel like I said
earlier a bit disadvantaged in that
sense but it's something that I I need
to and you said you were and you don't
have to talk about this if you don't
want to so feel free to not answer any
of this but you said um you were 17. how
did you meet him if we look through work
and did you did he know you before that
um yeah from what age like 15. oh wow
yeah
was he like a boss or something no he
just what's up mine look
um MTR you understand yeah this is the
type of conversation that um I typically
I think it's very important for the
women to talk to the women regarding
this conversation
um I kind of feel I got a place that had
a turn in order to enter information but
let me give you from my perspective of
something that I tell the men on my
channel is that
when you're vetting a young woman
one of the first places that you should
look at is the relationship between her
father
and you mentioned that you said that
your father was abusive
and one thing that we actually learn in
the conversation earlier today is like
like attracts like and if your father
was abusive you are more likely to
attract abuse going into the future
and I think that it Reigns true even
within this conversation I think there
was a lot of points that were made on
both sides of the coin from both Melanie
and Auntie Jenny that I think
um you should replay this video back at
the end of the day
um you have to be responsible for you
and
what you don't want to do is be a victim
into your singleness yeah
into until you're lonely forever and can
I say this you know it's a failure of us
as older women
that we should be
um you know being able to Mentor young
women who have gone through these things
and being able to be a voice so many
older women are competing they're taking
the same thirst trapping photos and
still doing the most only care about
themselves they don't care about their
children they're looking for what's best
for them but I think I'm 41 you're 21
we're 20 years apart and I was blessed
where my like my my sister and cousin
flew out with me like on a dime because
our father our you know our families
raised us where they have money we were
able to do what we want we're black
Americans which is it's very rare like
on I was like hey I gotta fly for
business I want to go hey girl let's go
like my sister bought a travel agency
just so we could travel and like get
discounts like like we're in those
positions and I say my sister is one of
the people who's mentored me like like
just talking to her but by family in
general and I think you know if you want
to hit me up and this is how I was
raised because my parents did a lot of
church ministry and things but if you
want to hit up and you want to talk to
an older woman who's not likely I'm not
your mother I'm not gonna you know but
if you wanna you know you know just you
know like hey can I
I I don't know certain things and I
think that we as older women have failed
this generation of women the younger
women and
um and we take I take accountability for
that not you know me specifically that
I've done it but in general and even
your mother allowing you to be raised by
a man who victimized you and did not
raise you you know in the way that you
should go but you can change that and
you can have a great outcome don't let
this Define you let it be just a lesson
to make greater you know say pain always
leaves a gift
[Music]
Auntie's been holding up her hand I'm
trying to be good just because you're
here right that's because you're ahead
that's what holds it up my hands no
um
um Melanie
um as older woman and I'm older than you
the young people don't want to listen
we're old school very good so I'm sorry
about I don't take that I understand
what you're saying and from your point
if you agree I'm tired of talking to
young people because they don't want to
listen so I'm I'm not going to nice it
up Pearl knows eppel wants advice and
she can't get hold of her mother purple
for me I'm gonna nice it out for pill I
would tell her straight that tree Pearl
I will tell two o'clock in the morning
I'm gonna tell her like it is I don't
give a damn how she takes it you ask me
a question I'm gonna give you an answer
I don't want to go around and I've been
talking to young people all I've been
Auntie Jenny now for 37 years I've been
Auntie Jenny Auntie Jenny's not a new
thing I've got the I've got the young
people now come and telling me Oh you
know what you tell them on your podcast
you told me that when I was young yeah I
did and you know what I've got to the
point now where cut the crap yeah you're
going out there you're adults things
have changed now things have moved on so
much you're on Instagram you're on Tick
Tock you're on this you're on that you
got your Android you're making your
money and I'm supposed to feel sorry
because you buy the bad life I've had a
bad life you know if it was a man that
would say man up yep now woman up I
don't give up
a fruit because now that you're in the
UK now there's free therapy I've had it
the first one didn't work at the second
one the third one I tried all different
kinds until it worked so that's why I
got to the point where I am where I
don't wanna I don't want to hear no
excuses for the UK because in the UK
they laid down they will lie down
backwards to help you
you want therapy it's there whatever
kind you want is there your ill is that
everything is free in the UK education
everything is free so I can understand
what you're saying from an American
point of view but from England I take no
excuses I'm tired of talking to young
people because they will look at me and
they would say ah this is what I've been
told it's changed now your old school
things are different but you know what
you think things are different but deep
inside the body the foundation of life
is still there it's been going on and on
and on so I'm tired of talking to young
people in a way that oh yeah let me be
nice yeah let me soothe it for you no if
it was a man if a man come to you and
they said oh I'm feeling a bit depressed
you say come on
so I've got to the point where if it's
good enough for the goose it's good
enough for the gander I've taken no
prisoners no excuses if a man can man up
a woman can man up it's there for you so
I ain't got no excuses you know what
because I'm the exception that nothing
that she ain't been through that I've
been through 10 times worse she was
lucky she come out of it without a child
I come out of it 17 years old with a
child hey you know what one child I've
still got 37 years old and you know what
everybody looked down at me I didn't
take no excuses I was in a basic abusive
relationship when I had my son I'll go
out of it less than a year I got out of
it with a child I was on contraception
because I'm an exception to every rule
so if I can do it I'm putting up a notes
you ask me for advice I'm going to give
it to you if you don't like it piss off
no and I that's my view you're a
frustration
the fact that we're going over the same
things over and over and over and over
and over again trying to make it nice
for the young modern women life ain't
nice
life ain't nice life is character
building whatever happens you spin it on
his head and make it build you make it
make you a stronger person this help out
there go and get it everywhere you go in
England now you watch yourself in
England
that is something the other day about
men because then I decided that men's
mental health matters at the end of
every sub and every English person will
tell you there's a phone number if this
has affected you or you have something
similar phone this number you will get
help that is in England so because all
the helpers out there I don't want to
hear it it's [__] no I understand
they want to watch stuff
they digest toxicity and one of the
things I would say Aunt Jenny you're
correct because one of the things I
would say and you guys have got to
understand her perspective and don't
take it as though she's been harsh or
whatever like we live in a very soft
generation like if you I don't know how
it was it I do know how it was in the UK
but if you understand what people went
through in the U.S I always bring up
Meghan Markle compared to Ruby Bridges
Megan Mark they're going in the
worldwide privacy tour complaining uh I
lived in a castle my brother got the
biggest size of the room and all this
other stuff I I came my first time in
the UK was to go to to that wedding
because I was proud of the situation and
I thought it was something great but as
I started to see the complaining I said
Ruby Bridges in the U.S there was
segregation between black and white
people in schools Ruby Bridges was
seven-year-old little girl she was the
first black girl to ever go into a white
school in the entire U.S if you look
back at the documentaries what she went
through black people particularly in the
U.S during segregation she stood what we
call ten toes down harder than Meghan
Markle because some Preston didn't like
her there was a little girl who stood
harder and you've never heard Ruby
Bridges say a word okay you Rosa Parks
you know people who went through real
oppression but it's it can be the victim
Olympics every person everything that
you went through Somebody went through a
thousand times worse if you look through
history but this is the thing this is
the thing it is a failure right now
because many of us we're so much into
our feelings my truth what is about me
it is such a self-indulgent culture we
don't care about the family it's about
me what my body my choice so you can't
say my body my choice but yet I was
victimized by a man so like is it you
you want sympathy to say well I was
victimized but hey it was your body your
choice so there are these these opposing
things the only thing I say is that if
we can if we can come to I feel like not
everyone's going to change I I go with
the 10 I go with there are people who
will stay hard-headed stay in Rebellion
stay in Pride and want what they want
lust greed and whatever and you're going
to get the results of that but if I can
if what you just said what I said the
combination of these things if we can
like talk to these young women and say I
understand let me like maybe uh Mentor
you I still think there's a
responsibility of us as older women's
and Mentor now if you have a mentee
that's hard-headed and will still want
to run the streets still making the same
choice you gotta go you're going to face
those consequences I don't hear but I
will tell you there are women like my
mother who it wasn't her choice it
wasn't her fault she made a choice she
decided to change she listened to these
nuns after she was thrown out if you
continue to be hard-headed you have to
understand life is going to throw you
horrific consequences if you don't
listen to a woman like Aunt Jenny you
think she's just popping off and she
don't understand if you don't take the
time to understand you want to be you
you want Direction you don't let her
guide you because you don't like the
tone this is what Kevin Samuels he was a
friend of mine they didn't like his tone
but now all of a sudden they do because
they realize they're not getting the
results and the same thing that you're
saying they don't like your tone but
you're fed up because you'll give them
you've given the soft tone you've tried
everything and they don't want to listen
so y'all have to understand there's two
sides to this coin and I just said when
my frustrations come from like your guy
in the back going back to history I was
12 years old and I come to England I was
a English woman went to Barbados come
back to the Jungle you know so it all
happened I was 12 years old and what I
don't what I felt Paul can say pearl
knows some of the women that I come that
come on this show and I blast them I
give them my personal number
to say well you know if you want to
change help me
and then I've got the men on Instagram
that I mentor on Instagram who do you
regular the man I have never had 100
year old girl with my therapy practice
before men I gave him my number I've had
numerous people on this show women young
girls
under 21 they've tried to help and do
they take it now because she's old
school but yet the men the men that I
talk to or the men that hear me they
phone me up oh aren't you Jenny can you
give me some help can you advise me I
have had the men phone up the show and
then I've said now you're fat just like
that you're fat to the gym and the guys
will come back and they'll show me one
guy came back and I looked him and I
thought
well guesswork
he'd got himself a girlfriend and he was
doing great but the girls
fantasy men can't be forever victims
because nobody cares about nobody cares
about their problems nobody cares about
Johnny Depp to me about their problems
and they change they take the advice
from me but the women don't what's
because the hardest thing to do is
change yourself you have to live with
yourself every day and and Men actually
look to solve problems with what women
just look to feel better most of the
time yeah I mean yeah
[Music]
but he's um that's the way it's spelled
but he's he's not no I have the men
phoning me up on my Instagram but the
women never phone up you sit here and
you say the same things over and over
again you try and give them help and
then they walk out of them it's like ah
she didn't know nothing but can I say
this to you if you hit me up my my
Instagram I'll give it to you okay if
you want to talk I promise you no it's
my responsibility and and no no don't
feel like you're bothering me it's my
job God has caught didn't put me on this
Earth just to you know for myself why do
you think
because
I don't know I I just I don't know the
way my mother raised me my my father
raised me I I don't want you to feel
alone you know in a lot of young women
don't have someone to say something
directly to them but this is the thing
I'm gonna tell you just like on Jenny
just said if you are I can listen to
another opinion I can listen to if you
feel something different but if I feel
like you're bucking and you're like
going to be rebellious and you're still
making choices with the same and if I
tell you listen these are red flags you
gotta stop I do this now my father's my
best friend my sister they will tell me
automatically I'm the MTR will tell you
I'm scared of my sister
okay like I'm terrified of her because
she loves me so much she wants the best
for me she's doing so much improving but
I know if she's given me instruction and
I've stepped out
oh I'm gonna get it I'm good she is
going to read me and I'm like terrified
of it but it's a good terrified because
I know she loves it she she wants the
best for me and she could see me being
if I'm being hard-headed same thing with
my father so you have to understand if
you reach out for help be prepared to
receive that help in the way that it
comes it's not going to come always in a
pretty package and it's not going to be
what you want to hear but if you have a
soft heart and a willing you you have a
will your ears are willing to listen to
digest doesn't mean you have to be
perfect but if you're gonna you know so
many women they they rebel against older
women they think well I'm young she's
old she don't know any better and we
don't know anything and we just want you
to times have changed you know you're
right and it's like times have not
changed people are still people and we
can see things from a different
perspective and like you think she wants
you to fail
even with all her passion and things
even with that do you think she's
feeling this fiery because she doesn't
care no of course not because I think
it's tough love it is it tough love is
good I think sometimes sensitive love is
also good I think uh our society right
now at the moment we're on the topic of
modern women I think modern women need a
bit more sensitive because
I feel like with your last generation
your parents would really tough on you
and I think a lot of our parents for
example like my mum and dad was quite
tough on me but I think our generation
is starting to learn more about like
psychology and more more about how
people actually feel and how people
should be treated so we've got a bit
more sensitive I actually I have a very
strong feeling on psychology I think the
more we learn about psychology the more
crazy become I think yeah the thing yeah
I say this I'm in getting my masters in
Psychology yeah not because I want it
but because I needed a Visa
I thought it would be to be honest it
kind of is
um yeah everyone in the program's crazy
I'm not saying there's exceptions but
literally they're all nuts literally
insane yeah
um I think but I don't I actually
disagree with you I think that we need
more tough love I don't think anyone I
don't think we everyone lies to women
whenever men tell us what they want we
Society lies to us and as I said body
didn't say that what she said did she
say you need to be more sensitive to
Modern women I was like yeah she said
yes
she said you need to be more you need to
ask you the absolutely that's what I
said I said we need to be tougher yeah
no but she yeah
she wants you to be more sensitive yeah
can I ask you a question so this
happened at 17 years old yeah and how
old are you right now I'm 21. okay seven
three uh four years ago three four years
ago yeah um do you still consider
yourself I think a victim of them no I
consider myself for someone who survived
it and somebody that um
like I feel like I could have done a lot
of things better I could have left a lot
of times when I didn't leave but I felt
like
I was just sort of sucked into like a
cycle
where I felt like I couldn't get out
can I just say something young lady
right what you need to do right is say
to yourself I'm a Survivor I'm not a
victim
no I'm serious you see what I mean do
you see what I mean yeah it's not a game
to be four years outside of the
situation happening and it's still
drawing tears out of you no I mean like
you know it ended recently as in like it
started about why were you in here but
you were in it for four years as an
adult and you didn't remove yourself
from the situation yes and again like I
said it's a mistake that I made that's
why you need more tough love because
you've gotten pandered to you've gotten
cuddled through it that's why you stayed
I didn't necessarily get cuddled because
again the only people that I was seeking
you needed a father to step into this
situation and say what are you doing
because obviously he's obviously not
into you yeah he's obviously doing he's
obviously right but that's tough love so
you don't need more of bit this you
don't need more babying you need someone
to step in and say this is this is what
a man is this is how a man should act
and if he is not
that version then you need to stop you
need to go somewhere else
model women today have been lied to and
here's the thing is that like you guys
want us to be truthful but at the point
that we're truthful then you start
crying then you start you know with the
victimhood then you start with these
type of things so it's so often times we
just let y'all just go off
we just let y'all just do your thing and
then again you're going to be single for
the next couple of decades with a low
level barometer hate for men okay I
don't hate men can I ask you
to hit you is that what would happen
um I'd say it was a bit less physical it
did get physical a few times but
um by just him emotional or was it
two-party
um mainly him no but would you hit him
too on one occasion I hit him back yes
uh I did and I never actually pressed
charges one of them because at the time
I
still loved him which is it sounds a bit
weird a lot of people don't understand
that concept
but I was I genuinely still loved him
even though
[__] happened she went on do you think
not pressing charges on him is a
component of tough love or it's a
component of being cuddled um it's more
of a component of me being
um sort of a empathetic person
empathetic person I tried to see the
good in people even when they've done
bad because I've done bad things and I
still believe I'm a good person so I
believe that other people are good yeah
they do bad things and I feel like I
if I
say for example I press charges on him
like he had a daughter as well if I
press charges on him that's not just him
going to prison but what if he hits her
that's I know exactly and that's another
argument I could be stopping over people
from going through that but I've because
again like I said I loved him at the
time I thought of it as like I'm not
gonna affect that okay if I get him
arrested it's not only just him that I
obviously I care about him I don't want
him to be in prison it's his child that
is going to be affected and then it's
just like a knock-on effect and I'm
curious
um I'm assuming when you guys were
together you didn't think you were
groomed right no I no so when did that
switch for you when did you decide you
were groomed when I I didn't I wouldn't
say I decided I was grooming well you
changed your mind on it yeah I'd say it
like when I left the relationship I
started reading a few books and I
started like looking into like new
things
um well he's currently 28. if he was 22
would have been growing if it was the
exact same situation I mean the thing is
I feel like you can get you can sort of
get groomed at any age
no if he was younger than you would have
been grooming no um
see I'm going to be careful on what I
see here because I don't want to say
that no I don't want to say that but I
just feel like I don't want to speak too
much on the situation because obviously
this is going to be out there and I've
got people that are watching and whatnot
so I don't want to speak too much on it
but I
I knew this guy from when I was 15 he
emailed me a lot and then he'd sort of
buy me gifts button me up tell me that
he'd be watching me and work when I was
like 16 and [__] like that and then just
sort of I don't want to say force me in
a relationship but well he did enforce
you in a relationship like I at the time
I thought I wanted that relationship and
then afterwards I seen all the signs of
like what he had done and how he had
gone about it and it it all lines up to
like grooming in my opinion anyway are
there things you're willing to call out
that um are specific to grooming as
opposed to just being a bad relationship
with someone consider abusive no
um there's a lot of specific things
obviously I'm no [__] sorry for
swimming but I'm not like psychologist
um and I'm no and the reason why I ask
is because I think uh men today and
again I don't know your situation at all
I'm just talking in general a lot of men
today have words that are weaponized
against them and they were just bad guys
one of the big ones is toxic masculinity
you know um because I am you know I have
shitty components within my masculine it
is therefore toxic right and it's a word
that's kind of weaponized and then
there's kind of this bad branding that
Trails them no matter what and you know
um two people again I don't know the
situation but there's people that are
watching that know you and that know him
and now they have a thought in their
mind that he's a groomer so that's why I
ask is to no the thing is it's most of
the people that I spoke to about the
situation that told me that like I
didn't realize until I had actually
because I when I'm in a relationship I
tend to keep a lot of things to myself
I feel like I it's between me and that
other person it's nothing to do with
anyone else there may be a few issues
here and there where I may seek advice I
may not exactly follow that advice but I
may just ask for other opinions and
again somebody said before there was red
there may have been red flags I ignored
and yeah again I'd say there was a lot
of red flags that I ignored but because
I was so willing to commit to this man
I decided to stay in that relationship
and endure what I endured because I
thought I loved this person but in
reality I felt like I was sort of
he
ah I don't really know what to say
anymore yeah
um like for me
I see where you're coming from
everything because you know I think a
lot of people have gone through these
things and they don't actually know
they've gone through grooming but
sometimes like some people will suss out
your sorry um they will kind of evaluate
your situations and see how close you
are with your family or your friends and
things like that and that's kind of what
makes it grooming because it's like if
you're young and under the age of like
18 like 16 or so and they're 30 and they
know you don't have a good connection
with your family or maybe you even like
maybe we're homeless or grabbing care or
things like that and then they can
appeal to things that you need because
you've never had anyone that can maybe
come across as agreement
right because to me like 15 is a bit a
bit like you know but
I don't know when I was 17 I knew what I
was doing yeah but I got 17 you know I'd
say you know what you're doing but what
business does a 27 year old man have to
do with it like in 15 16 17 year old I
mean is it 15 16 17 I mean it was when I
was 15 he was what he would have been 24
and then onwards from there wait he
started talking to you when you were 15.
yeah let's talk about how that's illegal
is that is that legal here it's
definitely illegal in the same 15 is
weird
the thing is it wasn't he was talking to
me in a sexual way it was in because
again like I said so it was like in a
friend friendly way but looking back I
felt like he'd bottom me up like he'd be
on my socials complimenting me like
saying [__] like one day I'm gonna wife
you [__] like that and I didn't see it
with yeah like 15 16. yeah yeah that's
weird that's illegal and I I didn't see
all the time and I genuinely I don't
know
I the first few years it was obviously I
I got I got with him when I was 17. so
it's not like I got with him when I was
underage
I was like 17 18 when I actually got
with him and started dating him and
whatnot and again like you said Pearl
you know what you're doing that at that
age I don't I don't sort of say I don't
know what I was doing yeah but again I
feel like I was in a vulnerable position
and I got taken advantage of you you you
were unwilling to make wise decisions at
that age up to 17 or whatever the
situation it ended up a year ago you
throughout that whole time you've been
you were incapable of making great
decisions
so what that does not need is more
coddling that needs tough love yeah
could I just say something right she was
um
she was working
oh she was working I you were old enough
to work I have been in uni um I'm old
enough to work yes but I have recently
left jobs no I don't do it on this
situation I mean when everybody's
talking about the age
when they got together all I heard was
they may at work yeah I worked I wasn't
working in a legal job cash in hand from
15 years old that's what I'm trying to
say so all right then if I go to a
workplace if you and me are going to
work right and I see you at work I'm
obviously going to think you're an adult
because you're working I'm not making
excuses unless you told him I am 15. I
did tell him and he told me you look 21
and you're mature for your age does I
excuse it I don't think it does no I
don't send excuses just because I'm
working it doesn't it it's excuses I'm
not saying it excuses it no but that's
I'm not saying it excuses it and this is
what I mean about you and your modern
people they always want you to be so so
soft and when you're trying to find out
what happens they always want to blame
the men because you're not letting me
finish saying what I'm saying you were
there working illegally right so the
first thing the guy could have seen was
that you're under eight that that you're
of age because you're working so first
start whatever your background is you
know you can work from the age of 15 16
as long as you have a national National
Insurance number
did you have your parents permission yes
I did right so you had your question to
work so why couldn't you have parents
permission if your parents gave you
permission to work why couldn't you go
to your parents and say this guy's
talking to me and I'm underage
yes ma'am when you were first talking
and as what I understood you was what
was first gonna say is that you can't
come out here and call a man a groom
unless you've got evidence for it
you can't cut my hair I tell somebody
something I got that I called somebody
like oh yeah I can turn around and say
my son doesn't abuser you know what
because everybody knows it's been out
there because I've taken him to court
it's been out there I've got an
injunction it's been out there but
you're gonna come on there and you're
gonna say all these things happen and
then you're gonna turn around and say oh
though
that's where the respect comes in I
haven't finished talking though and
that's the problem in modern women
and that's the problem because he was
trying to say the same thing you come on
here and you're saying them obviously
like you said the people know who he is
the people know who he is so as far as
they're concerned he was in a
relationship
now a groomer because he is
a groomer out there without a police
record
out there who hasn't gone to court for
grooming her this is what I mean
something that you literally do not know
people
in every issue
someone's out there without any any
subject or anything to do with you so if
you've got any other charger out there
it's not from what he's done to you but
it is so you can't go out there and say
oh I took him to court and I oh I could
have gone to court and I didn't press
charges
because if somebody does something and
you press charges it's not press charges
don't talk about the man don't talk
about him on social media because people
are going to be out there
I want to go with my son I can talk
about it because we're about to go do
you know how many people commit crimes
and do not go to prison for it and those
are the people that should be talking
about it those are the people when they
commit crime what does that mean when
they oh then when they commit crimes if
somebody commits a crime against you and
you don't want to report it shut up
about it what if you just got snitch
then you deserve to get abused I said it
no I said it I said it and somebody's
abusing you and you know that the police
are going to stop you and you decide to
sit there and you don't want to say
nothing well then you ask for it no
that's because you could have done
something about it you could have done
something about it rather than being
snitch so you don't want to be a snitch
but you want to sit here and be abused
person
right I shouldn't tell you I shouldn't
talk about it I shouldn't tell people I
got hit by a boss and I got brain damage
because it's a bad thing to say
something
it's cool it's a little bit different
than that because it's three sides to
every story he's going to have his own
yeah explanations of course if he was
describe the situation do you think he
would describe himself as a groomer
but it is immoral though it is
that just because
she's telling us
when she was 16. see see he might he
might then say well I didn't know she
was working at a spot and I thought you
had to be 18 years old
the point is we're going off of what she
says right and he doesn't have a
platform to talk about it but I don't
know you right so I could absolutely
that's
she's not the only one who's done this
like girls will come on the show and
this is why it was on the list because
girls come on the show and it's the same
story oh he abused me and they're always
with him for multiple years it's never
just one year like the first time I got
hit I left it's always multiple years
you could have your reasons for doing
that but to me if someone's hitting me
in the face I'm out I'm getting the [__]
out of there that's just me so you don't
know so unless you're in the situation
this guilt tripping is
I understand okay but and so then and so
then I asked did you file a police
report and oftentimes the answer is no
and so then we're going to a point where
she can say he did this this and this
I don't I don't you might have happened
it's okay
I'm talking about you okay I'm talking
about the point okay and so the point is
that many men get accused of crimes they
did not commit and when there's no
evidence and no police report I don't
know your personal situation but it's
weird to me that you were there for
multiple years and you didn't press
charges and you just continued to stay
and get hit because if someone hits me
in the face I'm going to the police but
so me personally I was enough for
multiple years um it was about 17 to 21.
no it was no you said 15. no I'm saying
he was grooming me from 15 to about I
was 17 years old and then that's when
things started getting and further on
well I'm telling you and so I'm not
saying that sorry no I know what you're
saying is again it re rates my point
before why I got upset about the list
because some women turn around and say
I've been abused I've been great I've
been this I've been that and it makes
the actual victims look bad and the
actual victims not want to report it
because you feel like you're doing
something wrong by reporting it and
especially if you've got someone in the
back of your 18 don't report me I've got
I don't want this to go wrong I don't
want that to go wrong like you're you
love this person and this person is
telling you all sorts it's hard for you
to do that report it then why would you
go around telling everybody
it just came up in this situation no no
you're going to report it on a podcast
for everyone to listen to why don't you
report it to the police where change can
be ha can be had what's the police going
to do apart from putting on the sex
offenders list and give me a restraining
order
I have a restraining order protect other
girls out there protect my grandchildren
and her his cousin and her sister and
everybody are all the other females out
there that's what you're doing when you
report something like that you're not
thinking about yourself you're thinking
about the whole everybody around you and
everybody around you you're protecting
everyone else once you let an offender
go you're leaving abuse everybody else
to the full extent do you know what I
don't disagree that he's done these
things he needs to be held completely
and utterly accountable and and this is
how men think when they're talking to
you and when they hear these stories
like there's so many men that have false
that have had false allegations yeah
against them like most men know someone
that was falsely accused I've been
falsely yeah so this might be harsh deer
but I'm telling you when they listen to
these stories they're gonna they think
oh [__] she she might be lying she might
do that to me because there's no
evidence
and I've been falsely accused and a
police report was not filed because she
was lying she was lying okay
and let's say he went to court and went
to Jerry it wouldn't have stood up is it
she completely made it up out of thin
air and the evidence would not have
shown exactly the things that she was
saying at that particular Junction
because her feelings made it feel like
something that happened or her back was
up against the wall in that moment and I
I everything that all of you guys are
saying right now it holds weight it's
validity to that and it it it just
brings us back to the topic of women not
being held accountable and being able to
go around saying whatever that is not
saying that your story isn't true or
anything of that nature but personally
this is still very raw for you and a
person has to be in a place where they
are ready to hear the um valid points
that are being given right the wisdom
the ingenious sharing even the points
that Melody is saying about coming to
her and being a mentor but if you are
not in a place where you can receive
that because right now in the moment you
are still defending the situation even
though your heart isn't to defend it
your heart is defending your feelings
and emotions around it but it just ended
in in October we are not even six months
away from that and it is as they are
talking you are being triggered and you
are reliving each and every moment and
that's not to it's what What's Happening
Here is you're going back through it
you're defending that and it seems like
you are rebellious to them and giving
valid honest good feedback for you to
grow and I know you're trying to receive
that and it's coming off very a tactful
to you and now you feel like you have to
defend yourself and you can't properly
receive the wisdom that is going forth
in the room because it's it's
re-triggering you so I just want you to
sit with this as he's already mentioned
make sure sure you go back through this
recording and you listen to the points
in a place when you are ready to
properly receive from it because it's a
lot of things that are being said that
honestly if you if you from the right
perspective listen to it and hear it
you're going to recognize that this
actually was a red flag that what they
said is true and in in even what they're
saying right now about calling someone a
groomer without the proper evidence no
one's saying that he wasn't a groomer no
one's saying that that wasn't present
but in the state that we live in where
women are being held accountable and
they go around accusing men how
dangerous that can be without action
behind it and that is the only point
which is a very valid point it is the
reality that we live in and it sucks and
it is unreal and so women like yourself
who have a Justified situation have to
deal with that reality but you have to
deal with the accountability too where's
the action that comes with it right and
we it's not to say that in the moment
things couldn't have been different but
I just want you to sit with that because
as another woman on this couch I can't
relate personally to that but I
emotionally and empathetically I feel
for you right now and I don't want you
to feel like you have to continue
defending yourself because that's what
it is listen um all I'm saying is
personally I did not want to mention
this at all on this panel I feel like
this is something that's quite personal
and again like you just said it's
something that's quite fresh to me so I
feel like putting it out there right now
was probably not
the best thing for me table something
that I wanted to do and I think that is
again why I'm getting a little bit
triggered because like I said it's quite
fresh to me I've only just started
speaking off about it and whatnot and I
think just hearing the point of view
that other people are trying to say that
I'm chatting [__] I think it is a bit
annoying because no
like that's why it sort of feels like
it's because obviously I'm not saying
yeah
you can't receive it and it's fine but I
need you to realize what you are right
because even your response to this is
still defensive and it's it's nothing
wrong with that but you have to sit in
that because everything that went forth
today was wisdom and it is a different
perspective and it's challenging you
right now because all of your emotions
are trying to justify and to protect you
and what you went through and while your
emotions may have been real in the
moment in perspective in time are they
valid is that the reality that paints
the picture of the holistic experience
in that moment what you felt and what
you went through was it real absolutely
but when in the perspective of time
vision is 2020 hindsight is 20 20. when
you look back on that and you take these
other factors and elements that everyone
has contributed to in this room you will
have a different perspective but right
now in this moment you're not hearing it
I'm gonna let her fit I'm gonna let you
talk because I think you keep getting
cut off so no sorry I do you genuinely
value all your opinions in there
obviously you are all much older than me
obviously you've got more wisdom and
more knowledge and whatnot
um but again like I was saying earlier I
just sort of feel like
I'm being quoting quote unquote as oh
this is just a modern woman this is how
she is and this is I'm basically I feel
like I'm sort of being put in a place
where I'm being categorized in a place
where I cannot change if that's what
makes sense I don't know who said you
can't change no one said that but I just
feel like I have voice it's like one in
one ear and have the other like I
honestly I'm about my auntie Jenny [__]
at this point it's like one end out the
other Mama it's like well holy you know
what right you know the one thing that
that stood out to me is that it's only
been about six months it's never too
late to report it and the most the most
the thing that's gone really right you
know the one thing that she said
he has
a daughter
right remember that he has a daughter
that's what's getting to me
is that she said he has a daughter
she was a daughter she is Somebody's
Daughter
I never man's a groomer groomer groomer
groomer they don't care whose daughter
it is
have a daughter
and it's never too late I got ranked I
reported it like two years afterwards
still got taken up you know what because
the evidence was there I swear for God
if I came across a dude that I knew was
a beaut was abusive and abusing his
daughter I swear for God oh man report
like come on what we want to talk about
this point
it's not adding up to me
um
[Music]
do everything
um accountability is Kryptonite a Mr
missing 44 the victimhood Power Hour
Timothy ml uh 300 Super Chat
wow and Thane matter I'm gonna get him
too
okay uh Thane Thane it's one of my
favorite super Chatters hello
um Timothy as well hello uh Pearl I've
got so much to say and so few characters
um I know this is random but I've been
wanting to say this for all the videos
I've watched my dream come true would be
to see a panel with you and Mala from um
Unapologetic Sydney Watson gothics and
baby even Shuan head together that would
be fire I don't know who two or three of
those are
um Amala could come I think I'm doing
something with her in like a month or
two
Dane um so much so smdh victim Olympics
here we go Mr missing um the story is
breaking down worse than
um M Shay a million plot and Shyamalan I
showed a man some respect bro I don't
know who that is
she was 17
um she when she was 17 he would have
been 22 a liar uh roko Auntie Jenny is
right you would have you could have went
to your parents but you didn't probably
because you wanted it um Terrell Clark
where were your parents did they allow
you to talk to grown men this doesn't
add up either way you had to hide it
from your parents or had bad parents
which wasn't Terrell Clark um there's
always a victim in every story funny how
that works every time you ask these
secondary questions the math doesn't add
up Lane's um blood just turning in now
Rocky Edwards gets the wmtr Auntie Jenny
Melanie any advice getting through the
younger um younger bro 25 black Moses
only be sensitive to women but tell men
to man up make it make sense
um Lou Casey standing off Ovation for
Auntie she's absolutely right on point
the coddling does not create strong
people Thane Matra he sent four hundred
dollars yeah
Auntie cook go off
um thin Matra MTR keep representing fam
tell him Auntie tell him I'm the
resident airstror um that Insight that
you gave Kevin Samuels chose you I truly
hope that you know as a fact thank you
for not quitting this this YouTube space
because of a much needed impact oh [__]
uh okay
um AC ropes police say the worldliest
woman um should add this to their
vocabulary blackest Panther advice for
21 lose the female therapist get a male
therapist in mattra with the rise of
modern day Olympics the world does not
owe anyone understanding D who add who
hurt you
one second one second
who hurt you okay done
um let me go back one second okay
the grant the great canyon will the
great canyon will make a 747 look like a
paper plane um slice of pie modern women
deserve to be treated like Queens if
they treat their men like kings first a
black something miss a king's Ace wisdom
has removed the toughest crust um from
good red Harps pit pip cheerio the
resident air softer the strength of
women is putting her personal desires
aside to help men build a legacy in
themselves on the resident airsofter
black men are still held to the saying
that we need to be twice as great only
to be get half as good women
um while modern has suppressed the
standards by just being women Sushi
could never end up getting a girlfriend
in America ended up getting a Japanese
wife and have been married ever since
women in other countries are prettier
more respectful less picky and have more
loyalty Matt butcher if your lady shows
any type of disrespect don't reply to
text calls emails nothing then maybe
she'll learn more from the future
um Pookie Drew something
um let
stop trying to be the perfect wife just
be yourself Tomo J if you start looking
at 20 looking at 28 you're a buzzer
shooter why not make the best memories
in your pride with a man you want to
grow with that is naturally crashing top
15 percent men don't want 28 year olds
um uh another 100 Super Chat
David evening I'm 33 I've been married
for 14 years three daughters oldest
being 17. I just want to say a big thank
you for you and your open sincere
debates that will help us get a better
understanding of each other I wish you a
great evening and best wishes wishes
from Poland women worked in pottery and
textile Industries for eons please stop
healing it's overrated a girl escaped
North Korea and was traumatized when she
heard about therapy
hot take modern women hip-hop is truly
detrimental to society this woman needs
Lauren Hill I'll take my response off
the air black is Panther please ask the
lady who left her man why are you not
willing to do what other women are doing
for her man why is he not worth your
submission if men were respected we
wouldn't have this epidemic of people
saying men are trash or toxic
masculinity Tomo J um nationally the
ratio of the births of to the side of
the population birth rate not nature I'm
telling you on I'm I'm telling on you
sentience Lord Gaines I Love You Lord
games Fawcett media Melanie dropped the
mic pivotal moment we are going to hear
about this one for about a while going
viral uh
need to see um someone from our it's
nice to see someone from Ireland on the
panel uh Let me refresh this really
quick actually
um let's do final thoughts really quick
I'm sorry guys it is so late I can't
believe I'll leave this this show went
um you know thank you to the final
remaining guests
um
any final thoughts social media you want
to plug you know anything you want to
speak your piece on speak now roughly 30
seconds or less go ahead and then go
across
tonight was the pivotal night thanks for
having me on the show Pro it's always a
pleasure that's all yeah thanks for
coming
my new my new lawyer
God give her a dollar I need a dollar
for a retainer I I remember that I
haven't been doing pro bono let's see I
got it
um go ahead
um so thank you for having me on the
show I've never actually done anything
like this before but I was trying to
come out of my comfort zone
um which I think I've done it was quite
intense but it was quite good so yeah
thank you thank you for coming thank you
um I'm gonna let I'm gonna have you go
go last if that's okay so um MTR go
ahead
Pearl thanks for having me fantastic
panel here tonight shout out to
everybody uh conversation towards the
end guy exceptionally turned up
um I just want to say this is like my
final thing outside of go follow your
boy MTR on uh YouTube the real MTR on uh
Instagram modernmanplaybook.com
um last thing I just want to say and um
it's for all the guys out there that are
still listening and watching is is that
do everything in your power to continue
to protect yourself
um at the end of the day you are guilty
until proven innocent um it's not the
same for women for women it's completely
opposite but for men you are guilty
until you are proven innocent when you
get terminology like groomer put out in
front of you one of the things that I do
in order to continue to protect myself
is I have cameras in my crib
the video Don't Lie at the end of the
day right so think through these little
things that you can utilize from a
technology perspective to continue to be
able
to protect yourself because at the end
of the day nobody will care shout out to
Amber Heard
um Auntie go ahead I'm just going to
keep it short and sweet to all the
American people and all the English
mothers Happy Mother's Day
oh yeah yeah uh Auntie what what else
what else come on we've been working on
this go what you gotta go look at my
YouTube channel
go and look at my YouTube channel
subscribe
we try to get you to 100K by When Auntie
Jenny
if you know me you know me um and the
only thing I would say is
um shout out to everybody on here um
Aunt Jenny you know speaking her piece
and and really holding accountability
but also to the young lady here because
most women would not be able to take
this fire and expose this truth and take
this heat and then come back and sit
down she took a break she didn't get she
didn't pop off like we've seen some
people and try to you know fight and do
all of these other things she just you
know in her emotions because of the
situation and it is very fresh
um and so I think uh um this may be a
New Perspective she's never even heard
before and I think it it also takes a
amount of Bravery from her but I think
it takes bravery from the rest of the
people in the panel who you know had a
different perspective because I think a
lot of times the other side of the coin
is not spoken about
um uh young men men in general have gone
through a lot of victimization but
they're not allowed to speak about it
um as well again you talked about Amber
Heard you guys know how I ride for
Johnny Depp
um and uh you know a lot of people
especially young men are being
victimized and they have no Advocates
and no one wants to hear their sob story
but I think as as if we can have these
conversations without demonizing you
know each other this is how we start to
make progress and I appreciate Pearl for
having these conversations and everybody
involved and I think if we can just
woosh off for a second and just you know
come together then we'll be good
yeah I'm just going to say um thank you
for having me here this is the first
time I've done something like this so
it's a bit um it's a bit new for me it
was a bit overwhelming as you can see
I've shed a few tears which I didn't
mean to do I didn't intend on today
um and again I do respect all of your
guys opinions
um it's something new to me again I
think I've learned a little bit about
the way you should handle situations and
take accountability and
you got a crash course yeah basically
Yes actually yes basically yeah
um obviously I do have a lot of work to
do and I know some people might think
I'm just throwing things out there I'm
not like genuinely if I could have kept
this as to myself as possible I would
have but um again I've learned a lot and
thank you for thank you guys for having
me on here
listen if I talk to Melanie in a month
or so and you had not reached out
[Music]
but I will I will I definitely will um
because it's important and it is our
responsibility as older women too you
know we can't just bust shots on you and
not take accountability to help you grow
forward
I'm Melanie I do thank you for that I
really genuinely do appreciate that like
no one's really ever offered that to me
so I think it's something that I would
benefit on and when I say like it's
something that I think would benefit me
um I truly do mean that's why I will be
reaching out to you so yeah thank you
again
um I'm going to read the last I think
there's a couple super chats at the end
uh thank you guys all for I really
appreciate it I know this went crazy
late so I really really appreciate you
guys the Troopers
um AC ropes uh Pearl please read the
list of words that women need to add to
their vocabulary I do have that next
show actually I'll I'll show you guys
but I do a live stream where I go over
all of it
um
it's like three or four maybe five live
streams ago roughly I can't remember the
title off the top of my head but I'm
sitting at a desk
um controversial videos and gym
something um his daughter is full of
crap um report him period
um the or he has a daughter crap report
him um rational mail respect is a
gendered concept men men's respect is
merit-based men must earn respectability
women's respect is egalitarian unlearned
and expected women deserve respect for
being women M J's uh do everything
accountability is Kryptonite Mr missing
the victimhood Power Hour uh Let me
refresh it real quick I think I'm done
um
oh wait no there's one more okay
she needs to make her IG private ASAP
for her own safety and health well me
listen
um okay guys a couple announcements
before I end the show um as you already
know two clips channels go subscribe to
both just Pearl eclipse and pearl daily
doing a meet up tomorrow
um in central London sign up for the
email list
um blessing can you make sure it's in
the pinned comment after the show the
form um so we're gonna send out
um an email and text notification in the
morning with the exact time and location
we're pretty much set on one but just
you know in case there's any changes
make sure you guys are signed up to the
email list
um
and all former Show members are invited
so if you guys want something to do
tomorrow uh 5 30 p.m uh four membership
tiers uh let first hear you to be a part
of the chat second tier Discord and
Vlogs third tier connect with me on
social media in a four fourth tier a
one-on-one call with me once a month do
you want to know how to get a million
subscribers in a year I will tell you
sign up for that one uh sign up follow
my Instagram just pearly things one
we're almost a 200k on Instagram and oh
my gosh I'm on Twitter now uh follow me
on Twitter pearlythings with the Z and
I'm almost I just hit 100K on Twitter so
I'm killing Twitter uh we're on Rumble
follow wife school you know if you need
guidance you can come in for an episode
we can learn to need bread together uh
um
then oh follow my two follow Auntie
Jenny's chant Auntie Jenny's Channel and
King Richie's Channel those are the two
talents in the network uh we also just
pearly animations and we have one
official pregame page on Instagram so go
follow that as well thank you so much
for watching guys like the video on your
way out and I will talk to you next time